two happy Friday everybody hello we're
here I'm sipping my throat coat
you're spitting my mouth
uh first minute of the show yeah I need
to keep my throat coated
thank you somebody understands me
[Music]
um
yeah uh by the way shout out to throat
code our Saudi benefactor who donated
500 before the show even started oh my
God he knew I'd be sipping the throat
coat today's episode is sponsored by
gamer subs thank you we love love
I can't tell you the amount of people in
my real immediate life who are like I
usually don't like these kinds of drinks
but I love gamer sub yeah I heard of uh
someone in my real life was like I can't
stop with the Pina Colada flavor have I
done one
do we have that one no you usually
hitting that black cherry exclusively
right you want to try that peanut butter
do you like pina Cola I had it it was
good I love pina colada flavor getting
caught in the rain I love pina colada
different flavors
yeah yesterday
um we had to cancel I canceled the
leftovers because
you can probably hear my throats a
little hoarse after our like super Long
Reach and Babel episode I didn't realize
how [__] up my throat was I think I
was in the zone
and by the time I got home I was just
like oh brother it's been hard I don't
know what's going on but my oh they're
still squeaking man I'm sorry I said
somebody
I'm sorry
okay
yeah we're not even talking about them
today I think that was my favorite part
of the whole episode yeah I I kind of
agree the squeaking had very good yeah
yeah I like that
and I do feel it perfectly encapsulates
the thought process of our dear friend
reach yeah wow
wow okay calm down
so anyway
um first of all ela's looking fantastic
she showed up thank you Irma's looking
real good today
I you know what I said to ELA when I saw
her I said hey you guys are gonna love
this I said where's the rest of the
jacket
he still got it people well my dress is
the first um pick at our Marvel
collection that's gonna be coming out
pretty fresh Marvel like either this
week either this coming week or the week
after
universe
show it off you didn't show it off
enough it's venom you only see this one
we'll take we'll show you know I mean
show venom
it's venom Venom's cool he's a symbiote
just a taste of what's to come you guys
got some good photos today yes we did
the girls team ELO's got a girl squad
now it's kind of awesome why do you look
so much taller than me can you lower
your seat
wait why
bro rise to the occasion
oh maybe oh no
oh
he's up are you just sitting wait how do
I
entered all the way how do I
even there's a lever you just it's not
doing anything maybe it's down we have
an Apple box behind you if you want to
sit down here yeah you want a booster
no I just want you a little lower Street
Apple
am I doing it wrong
there's this right here yeah you pull
that oh on that side yeah just lower all
the way okay
I'm not doing this show from here I'm
not doing that it works for me I'll give
you like an inch lower
exactly okay
um I can settle on this
compromise yeah so I've been dealing
with this like crazy gerd where
it's been so bad that like when I sleep
if my head isn't elevated enough I just
had stomach acid sitting in my throat
and I think that's what's causing all
the damage yeah that's terrible
it is it is it's been terrible it has
been really terrible I don't know what
to do
I've only had that happen to me when I
was pregnant and it was so uncomfortable
you had the thing where if you lay down
you feel like yeah you can't it's like
for some reason because everything is
pushed to the top right I'm burping a
lot and so when I'm laying down I can't
burp
it's just not coming out and you could
feel the fluid bubbling geez yeah it's
hard it's the worst thing ever
okay okay I think I have a solution for
you
so you're gonna hop up
that guy looks super happy to be in that
bed why is he
yeah is that guy I think that's a
cadaver
I think that guy passed yeah that's
awesome man they're really selling it
get me in that baby
I'm stoked
Centro bed
get right on it order one right now
um but we have actually a really fun
show here which is obviously a change of
pace for us
we have uh hey Gabe one sec we've got
Martin the water simulator coming in I
never got to meet him in person so
that's great he's not only bringing
um some exciting waters for us to try
yeah but we actually uh are invested in
what's called water talk
which is a group of hooligans on a tick
tock
did you hear that
it's so beautiful
I did hear that
but uh
um whoa he's water themed so we're we're
preparing water talk recipes because
they try to make their water more
interesting okay for us all to sample
along with Martin and then
Dr IDs is calling in finally to settle
this great debate which I'm sure he's
going to side with me okay and that the
World Health Organization who are a
bunch of quacks and losers put out a
statement saying don't drink artificial
sweeteners but the press report was
[__] there's nothing in it and
Doctor isn't going to confirm that to me
today I'm so excited to be here for this
meeting of the minds yes it's it's a
very it's a symposium you know Abba
accused me of being an intellectual and
well
he may have had that's the biggest lie
that he told ah you a [__] do you feel
bro
if you're not you haven't even responded
to me yet you made me defend this dude
didn't make you do anything sorry Gabe
how you doing buddy that's a beautiful I
love the water setting is that on theme
or water yeah there's blue
and blue blue
shirt Blue Water
nice dude I love it nice what's behind
you a gingerbread house where are you
on by the waterfall like by the golf
course
oh you're at mini golfing yeah back on
the mini golf course
who you with
who you golfing with my buddy let me see
him gambling Buddies
oh they're over there you you took a you
took a a walk
baby you hit any balls on the freeway
today
nope nope good job
good for you [__] baby [__] my dick
oh yeah yeah I love that shot [__]
check on my dick
you don't like water oh you got water
oh
wait back to the Earth what is this
betrayal back to the Earth Dan really
we're refilling the water water
for the other people that can drink yeah
then he's filling the water reservoirs I
don't like that I would like that
they take it they've mined the water and
Gabe's puts it back Gabe's got a mission
it's act like water did you say you
don't like water
if you don't like water put it back in
the reservoir so people can drink it
yeah baby
[__] yeah baby Back To Nature I can't do
the woo
so he doesn't like water since when yeah
did you say you don't like water
well I have to have water for my health
you know you don't like water you put
some flavoring like
it's going to make it taste better oh
you just put straight up Splenda in your
water
yeah wow how long have you been doing
that
for a while so Gabe is actually the
Trailblazer yeah this man's been putting
Splenda in his water for years I see
because water's boring as [__]
it is [__] water if you can't drink
water they put like Crystal Light or
some like sugar-free additive
wow it's not sugar but it's at the it
has to kick into water oh yeah water is
boring [__] yeah baby who drinks that
[__]
the slander bringing Martin in on this
day don't you feel bad for animals they
have to drink like water out of a creek
without Splenda idiots [__] loser
animals losers
they don't care sausage water [__] oh
you they don't care okay that's good for
them
so you drink water with Splenda do you
have any other exciting ways of um
Crystal Crystal let me see
the light um the iced tea with lemon the
best okay
so we're drinking tea
that's good sounds like an Arnold Palmer
uh Gabe have you ever uh tried a product
called uh gamer sups
gamer stuck never heard of it oh really
maybe it's worth it GG slash H3
opportunity yeah we'll hook you up yeah
sure it's a great beverage
it's like water but better right okay
let's cut to the chase game I gotta ask
you something
yeah you posted a picture
with a uh
with a young lady
got us all talking and wondering
can you see the photo
Frankie Clark I bet she's watching it
right now it's a great dinner okay now I
gotta ask you a few questions okay Gabe
sure okay
you've mentioned that there's a special
somebody you've been trying to cuddle
with is this her
she's crazy about me and you know I
didn't get I gotta keep respect to her
you know whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
do you mean so she's interested in you
but you've rebutted her her uh her
advances her advances
well I gotta I gotta take it easy I
don't I don't know her so I just gotta
be respect right now okay all right
Shout Out game
do you like to hang out that's what
matters I got to get to know her first
wow so you guys went out for dinner
where'd you guys go
we're outside
Beverly Hills San Andreas
[Applause]
I I don't say it like that but I don't
know how to say it we've been there yeah
we have on my birthday oh what pastio
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that place is
awesome yeah all right I call it El
pastio yeah I'm sure I'm saying I'm sure
we're not saying
[Laughter]
so did you pay or did she pay or did you
guys half half
no I I take care of it I'm I'm a
gentleman I gotta be a gentleman what a
guy
so this is very interesting to me okay
wow so there's another potential cuddler
out there so who's the other girl this
is very interesting the second cuddler
her name is Frankie Frankie Clark okay I
guess oh oh just got her nice guy just
gave her a full name out huh nice and
what's her and what's her address
don't say no address no
I'm Gonna Keep it Friday
so when are we going to see a picture of
the other one
okay
dude Gabe is back Daddy dude he's out
there
fancy Italian dinners That's my boy
good night kiss did you guys hold hands
I mean what happened
nah just stop it's a formal talk just a
formal know each other right that's all
like you know it's like kind of like
interview what we like you know some
good things she likes fried chicken and
she likes um Borat that movie okay so
there's a good crossover Borat and fried
chicken we're at a good movie
me too yeah so that sounds like maybe a
good second date is Borat and fried
chicken but it wasn't a date I don't I
don't realize was it was it I had to
call it a day but it's just like a a
dinner it was a formal it was a predate
maybe
Maybe
oh good for you man
there it is there it is
there it is
I hope that the other girl isn't jealous
when she sees this post or were you were
you like maybe maybe I should let her
know that there's other fish in the city
yeah she's busy the other girl's busy
she's gonna she's gonna be gone for the
summer so she's so busy bro I don't know
yeah she's busy
what did she do what is she so busy
doing
that's like um
like it's like doing producing musical
videos and stuff so okay lots of
traveling
yeah lots of trouble oh it does sound
busy that's gonna be tough if you guys
settle down and get married and have
kids and stuff I just wonder if the
traveling could be a
the constant traveling could be a
hindrance to your guys's relationship
but that's that's a question for down
the line yeah don't worry then I don't
want to broaden it up yeah I do not keep
my respect
absolutely always
good man
what's your score on the mini golf
course you doing good
that's okay I get like you know three
four tries and that's it
kind of stay under par are you in the
middle of a of a course right there I
saw a whole family behind you
just gone
awesome Gabe love to hear from you
and uh here's DJ Khaled uh doing some
golf that might inspire you while you're
out there on the golf course here it is
yes
[Music]
something's happening
what happened
another one all right Gabe have a great
day okay always a pleasure
have a great
have a great [__] day have a great
mother [__] day tits of my butthole
[__]
squirt milk in my butthole with your tit
[Music]
how about this get a glass of water put
some Splenda in it and then give me a
[__] uh
what do you call it when you do
colonoscopy
enema yeah
Splendid water [__]
oh
nailed it all right who the [__] is
Uncle Gabe all right
listening
all right buddy you have a great one
okay we love you
have a great Memorial Day weekend be a
long weekend
another one
suckling
hasta la vista baby
already
okay
Gabe is intimidating me
[__]
[Applause]
and love beautiful love cap off the
convo
my throat is already hurting oh no going
to be a problem
uh oh I need more throat coat uh I
actually Gabe
gave you a nice little segue there to
mention uh that Memorial Day is next
Monday yeah and this Monday this coming
Monday yes we are take we're giving the
crew a day off and
including ourselves okay
uh everybody
let's honor the troops in in memory of
the troops the Fallen
we memorialize you all the troops from
Memorial Day speech let me just read
this all troops everywhere from every
country we memorialize them again thank
you for inviting me
to join you today during this Memorial
Day remembrance at this beautiful Park
on this beautiful day
every time I visit the park I walk by
each panel of the original monuments to
read the names of the Local Heroes lost
in the Second World War
then I stopped by the statues of
soldiers and small children with the
names of those lost missing from Korea
Vietnam
which hopefully someday will also
contain the names of over 60 Nebraskans
lost from our most recent conflict in
Iraq and
Afghanistan
Omaha and the surrounding communities
have borne a large burden of art Nations
fallen from the Civil War
[Music]
hold on Nebraska why are we honoring
Omaha hold the [__] and phone what are
you reading we honor you more about it I
just typed Memorial Day speech and
opened up this motherfucker's speech
from 2013. Major General William
Grimsley
Chief of Staff U.S strategic command
hell yeah we love Omaha well hold on
hold on hold on
Nebraska was was on which side of the
Civil War
I should know this because uh it was one
of the states that the uh the compromise
was involved in because because I'm not
sure I want to be memorializing
I think it was the north okay
Nebraska they were in the union we're in
the union well we honor them
Fallen Soldiers Yankees to the end they
were strongly against the secession in
fact [__] Nebraska forever dude
that's it that's America
we honor of the Fallen Nebraskans
from Nam to Korea to Iraq all the way
back to the Civil goddamn War which we
won by the way thanks to their help yep
oh [__] yeah we won
who's that right there who are you
oh you're with Martin okay
no I'm not trying to be rude I was just
curious you're like right I was just
curious who I was looking at who do you
what do you do with Ryan you just a
friend
are you
oh hey nice to meet you
he said he's a longtime Eva Kleiner
sorry I couldn't hear you said he's an
American he's just feeling patriotic
right now pledge allegiance
brought so rapper oh gosh what
that sounds very famous well we'll have
to pull it up yeah yes so he's a friend
of Martin's from the restaurant who I
guess is a fan who wanted to come say hi
what was your name again
Brendan hey Martin give us a sec okay
but love you guys
all right
yeah [__] hell man Nebraska forever
bro shout out to Nebraska
damn
no independent War uh uh Independence I
guess they didn't exist then huh
probably I was just saying where's the
clout for the men who followed to the
English
was not one of the 13 colonies I know
Nebraska Sorry probably not even close
okay
so um I want to say right here real
quickly at the top
or my throat completely
needs to be coded
that the women's Classics yes which we
are hyping up the other day has dropped
what it was Classics bare ear hoodie
from his classic hoodie pants zip up
Hoodie
that's right I was just wearing the
T-shirt this morning and I was thinking
to myself I need like 10 of those wait I
was just taking that too because I don't
the women's t-shirt Lena do we have can
we get me like one of each or actually
give me like two of each
shirt color pocket teeth me too the
women's also I'm gonna need um
shorts
of each color
I also feel like the women's zip up is
just like the perfect fit yeah so fun so
good really fun it's just a little bit
cropped but not crop crop exactly exact
is so good here's it is on the model
crushing it
love her
love her Sabrina she's so gorgeous and
so um
can I get two of in the in these two
colors Lena do you see that
thank you
and then we also have a little denim
jacket and a long sleeve that was
um a mini small collaboration with an
artist that I love cat Rose
these are her drawings
and it's really cute it is very cute
you're not kidding and a long sleeve
yeah
David says
[__] yeah so there it is teddyfresh.com
thank you
um
you know what's funny on the so we had
this really fun moment on our members
stream on Tuesday where
some this always happens people
recommend they go oh listen to my music
and I'm always like do you really want
me to listen your music because you're
gonna put me in a tough position where
I'm gonna have to say your music sucks
because your music almost definitely
ain't gonna suck
okay just by okay sheer odds I mean I
don't think I've ever
at best it'll be like eh but this girl
she sent out in the song
and it was I only had 17 views after
like two years phenomenal really they're
all freaking out oh my God and I would
love to play you all of her her
um
her name is the violettas and her name
is uh Elizabeth something or other
Elizabeth Holden and I would absolutely
love to play this for you but Elizabeth
you claimed me like [__] 12 times
and I literally go I go Elizabeth as I'm
listening to other music I said I don't
want any disc distro kid [__] claims
what is with these people they get you
know what I mean it's like 17 views and
you're claiming me I know it's probably
by mistake oh I know it's not her but
like these these
whatever the [__] their company
it's crazy yeah yeah there's a tab you
can click like to allow it to claim it's
so stupid right but I'm sure that she
didn't mean to because she was you know
over the moon but um she's awesome go
listen but I I guess was it released no
I just thought it was funny because
they're not gonna release it some random
[__] company they probably don't even
check it just takes 30 days to release
eight claims for each song
and I did a whole speech about Elizabeth
no [__] weird companies claiming my
[__] right
listen to it after the show check it out
though
it's very good cool
that being said
can play it
shout out Elizabeth
look check out the my uh
check out the episode claim page this
isn't even all of it this is just a
screenshot
this is my all my claims and it keeps
going I just I was like what the [__]
come on come on
who you kidding yeah
um
gotta leave my throats going fast faster
than I thought it would yeah it sounded
rough buddy are you ready to um host can
I get some more throat code all right
what do we do here today wow
I'm sick
well one thing uh we should do
potentially is uh our ad because we're
almost at 30 minutes already okay okay
so so quickly before that I just want to
say
to everybody who enjoyed our um
Babble and preach episode yesterday
thank you everybody who watched that I
know we went pretty hard and long on
those guys but you know what it is this
guy he's been calling and saying the
most heinous [__] you can say about
another person frankly excuse me of like
lying about essay and yeah just the
wildest [__] you know doxing people for
fun at first I didn't even know what you
guys were working on because I saw all
you guys work so hard on all the
research for it yeah I didn't know
what's the deal but I I think it's good
that you did address it because it's
just put it out there it's all such
[__] too and the thing you know
these guys enjoy like a good reputation
like people don't criticize them and I
think it's time to break that [__] uh
break that taboo which they're all about
right they're all about breaking time
um also an interesting comment came up
you guys might recall when um
Babel was like you said we're
disingenuously hold on where's the one
where he says I think young girls are
disgusting
I know real quick uh while you're
looking for that I just want to say if
you are having problems and you are on
an iPhone or an iPad You Are Not Alone
apparently Google they have not fixed
that and I'm seeing a lot of reports
that uh they are crashing non-stop uh
weird yo what if you have the ability to
watch on a different device either a
desktop or Android device if you have
one available
um it's working great there but if you
if you have updated the YouTube app uh
within the last week you might be kind
of food YouTube why are you doing this
and I'll tell you what else YouTube's
trying to [__] ruin my business that
whole episode of Babylon reach got
demonetized because there's a scene
where um Babel takes a blow up doll and
slams it on his head five seconds four
hour podcast and they said he was
motorboating it which is a sexual act
crazy that was so crazy
that's good use of the Laughing yeah
I'm running a [__] business here dude
and now people can't but it was like it
seems so harmless and also how could you
have known that that would be an issue I
wouldn't well I'm sure it got Mass
reported by their fans and stuff but
that specific moment that they uh come
on guys
yeah but um
somebody pointed out about Babel this is
good he says wait we're gonna glaze over
young women are disgusting by the guy
who previously worked in child welfare I
didn't know that but the way he oh Jesus
we're melting oh God
something is beeping there's a
everything okay Dan
it's our battery backup it's overloaded
we're figuring it out
so
they could everything's fine though I'll
keep going yeah yeah
so I thought that was an insightful
comment he's like I [__] hate young
girls they're disgusting
and uh I thought that was pretty good so
wasn't that interesting also one more
thing I you know my feeling on them is
that
after eight videos yeah I'm saying the
most heinous [__] possible about me
they're gonna be enlightened now and be
like no we don't need to respond we're
gonna take the high road now yeah well I
don't think they have their IQ to
properly respond like everything they
were saying that you showed was so dumb
I I couldn't believe what I was watching
I don't think they're dumb I just think
they don't do any they don't work on
their videos well they they also like
it's also like you said they are
pandering they know what Their audience
yes yeah and they just play into that
Elizabeth Holdings in chat she said I'm
so sorry I didn't know they would do
that I'll fix it yeah I know I know I
know you didn't
it's just funny after I yeah after
everything but there was some really
dumb [__] like horrible the part where
is like women um choose not to learn
from the data women
if you believe in global climate change
you have to believe the science jokes
don't do anything to anyone anytime oh
my God yes that one but um and also what
they said about Olivia is unforgivable
right yes of course
okay if you don't know who Olivia is
she's the loser feminist researcher who
spends all her Day on Reddit boards and
thinks that's research okay [__] what
the [__] research do you do how dare you
oh [__] I'm sorry but like y'all put
out a video like every day and it's
clear you don't put any work in this is
how these guys do videos they play video
they react to it they post it there's no
thought there's no prep and that's why
they can't possibly respond to our
well-reasoned thought out three and a
half hour podcast because they don't
know how to actually respond to
something like that all they do is play
a [__] video and respond this isn't
fresh and fit just being goons but the
thing is they owe me an apology and some
corrections and so I'm definitely not
going to let them weasel out of it like
they didn't say the most heinous [__]
imaginal about me for a [__] like
close to a year and here you go before
you try to ignore this and act like it
didn't happen Babble all of a sudden you
want to take the high road because
[__] after you made eight videos on
me coward [__] listen to yourself
you said we're disingenuous we're
cutting you out but you just admitted
you don't even know the context of what
we said you don't even you call this a
liar you call this a liar yeah you
figure that we lie we said you said that
we clip you say that we take things out
of context proved all those but you just
said that we don't watch you don't watch
this [__]
just do a live stream and showcase how
we took things out of context literally
did that in three and a half hours so I
mean we're the greater context and if
we're right and you showcase it I
promise you I'll get up here online and
the next day I'll admit I'm more okay
[__] the next day passed the next day
already passed you liar are you a [__]
okay so here's what I'm waiting for my
apology for lying about me skipping the
Hassan video they went on this whole
like five minute rant about how I'm a
[__] because I skipped the video they
made defending Hassan which wasn't on
the screen
what's not on the screen so the date
your day date line uh your day
Date Line deadline has passed that
apology is late from you my friend also
you said I'm homophobic you want another
five-minute rap at home hopefully when I
didn't mention anything about gay
anything about gay at all so I mean
that's another apology and I do think
and this one obviously isn't for me but
I do think it would be nice as a bonus
apology to apologize to the girl you
doxed and harassed from from fresh and
fit
and especially after they said I doc
someone and should be permanent which
was also crazy yeah so I mean I just
want to get it out there the dog thing
the definition is that you are showing
something that is not public with the
public yes
so we didn't do that but you did do that
you did do that you literally you
literally did do that okay
so as I sit here uh waiting for the
apology that was promised to me I remind
everyone that you are thinly veiled red
pill [__] losers basically diet fresh
and fit and every day you don't respond
you just look like [__] cowards who
can't back up anything they said about
me and aren't accountable to anything
they ever said so with that being said
have a great weekend you [__] heads
[Applause]
no that's so good if you like if you
don't want to respond go go on with your
life but just go to sleep knowing you're
living your life pandering to what you
know people want to hear from you you're
not actually being treated to yourself
leave it either that's the thing well
they're just not they don't want to know
they don't care they don't care I think
they do Karen they've been sad I think
they know exactly that if they put like
crazy Ethan Klein oh yeah that in the
title or crazy feminist oh yeah it's
gonna get million views you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but so you guys uh
I'm here
you know what I mean
and I'm definitely not I'm not done you
know what I mean like I told you guys
last week they didn't believe me
I said
straight up I'm [__] crazier than you
and I'll do and I'll do this whole thing
if you want and I'm sorry you think that
internet beef is cringy even though you
made eight videos about me but I'm here
bro and I'm gonna hold you idiots
accountable Babylon preach Babylon reach
[__] Creek and reach
creaky ass floor losers pandarin Creek
pandering Creek
is never gonna stop you know what I mean
you guys opened the Pandora's Box that's
Ethan Klein and it's babbling pre-season
out here in HP podcast so I hope you
guys enjoy the flavor
the love that all different flavors all
the different flavors Boy Yes Babylon
leech
Pander and leech it's all happening
I'm glad you think it's funny I think
it's funny too I'm gonna enjoy the whole
ride I hope you guys do too I wasn't
kidding they made a video about like oh
Ethan's oh Ethan's a [__] douche okay
we'll see
thank you guys waiting for my apology
appreciate that all right so let's take
our sponsors and then we'll get into the
Martin's gonna join us for a wonderful
water-based segments wow what a treat
he's excited
what's that
oh Spade pocket I can't swallow the
water
uh Martin wants me to spit the water out
we'll see about that
all right let me think oh there's the
gamer sub ad isn't uh highlighted
there's no URL I got it here
thank you today to our wonderful sponsor
gamer suck Who
such a fantastic supporter of the show
and who we love so well go ahead now
thank you yeah these guys are the best
man and I once again I'm telling you
guys
you don't think you'd like a lot of
people don't think they'd like a drink
like this but they all come back
I've heard about the mango the Pina
Colada from people like I would never
drink this but I can't stop it's so good
it's hydrating
you can get with caffeine you can get
without caffeine I personally like the
caffeine one I like to stay energized
and hydrated
tastes awesome you can get a fun cup
it's got electrolytes and all that kind
of stuff
you know what I mean and I hear it comes
from a natural spring
out in uh
Switzerland
the powder just emerges from
Gamers up has a new lemonade flavor they
dropped today
and it tastes great
they also have a new polarized cup do we
have that cup
this cup is so cool
oh this one or this one
oh we're using it in this segment yeah
so that's good you'll see it soon so the
new polarized cup which you'll see soon
also we are crafting a flavor which
we're all excited about yeah you know
this thing's coming out and we've been
in the lab all of us
and I think it's my favorite flavor we
called it Sigma brain oh really yeah
because it enhances uh it increases your
IQ and that's backed by science
peer reviewed now it tastes great
the actual flavor of it is spicy
margarita but we thought it's a better a
different name would be more fun I also
like zesty margarita
yeah zesty spicy
but all different flavors but a mango
black cherries the one I drink pina
colada I mean they're they're all good
and it's fun to try all the different
flavors they have they have a ton
you know get all the different shakers
it's what it is man we love gamer Subs
gamersubs.gg
use the code H3 you get 10 off your
order
thank you for two camera Subs man
for continue to support us and thank you
to everybody who uh has been buying
gamer Subs it all helps the show so
thank you guys
[Music]
all right
should we set up
let's bring out the man
the legend
the mythology
they're they're all good the drip King
he's dripped out Martin is always
dripped out that's true
foreign
that seems like diarrhea like
this kind of third sounding like this
yeah it sounds like the last dribble
Martin welcome hello hello hello
here comes the nice glasses
stunning and then um
uh
what was his name again
Brandon will you be sitting with us
you sure so first of all
this is like kind of bad I'm sick so
don't hug me let's do it like this you
don't want this but yeah before I want
to release something oh
like I said
like I said awesome
thank you like I said Martin has always
dripped out
[Laughter]
oh the water smellier is back in the
building you're gonna you're gonna chase
with me guys son yeah you see we may do
your own uh background there take a look
take a look look at the screen
water is not just water that's you nice
nice nice I brought some special borders
as well
I heard you want to drink with me water
and I was a little bit afraid what you
kind of waters you bringing in so I
thought I need some back up okay so
here's my son here's our plan
I yep you spend a lot of here we go Tick
Tock have you heard of water talk yeah
okay good I don't know what that is
obviously but I heard about it let's say
like that so you have some preconceived
notions about water talk I I I saw one
or two videos and I almost had a heart
attack okay because I was mean damn
we're debating which way you would take
it yeah so we're gonna review some water
talk videos together okay and then Sam
Samantha is in the laboratory creating
special waters for us to enjoy together
again that's the reason I asked for my
spit package so oh
do you drink Martin do you not drink
um flavored beverages or Cokes or
anything like that I brought you a
flavored water but I will release this
later on what I consider a great
flavored water okay okay yeah yeah but
by by these being said I know you have a
little drama about accountability I just
heard it I had exactly the same guys
like you know my my little fun with the
kangan MLM people so last week somebody
on Tick Tock thought it would be fun to
make a debunk video of Martin reason and
she started her whole sequence of this
guy is ridiculous he has a punchable
face oh my God
first of all right so punchable so I did
a video maybe you should see it because
the video is hilarious very very fun
video where I debunked them and I have
to say thank you so much for all the
amazing food soldiers because you killed
that lady like you literally like she
had to she had to obviously get rid of
that video Tick Tock uh right away
pulled that video then she had it still
on Instagram on Instagram she deleted
that video as well at one point it was
crazy listen now I had so much fun last
week that was the spritzer crew or the
water boys
so here it is lady wasn't the same but
yeah you've been going to war with the
Keegan people right yeah but that yeah I
don't know if you know that it's a
multi-level marketing [__] were they
yes sell this super expensive ionizing
machine they have a boot camp in Orange
County where they all get trained
they're all getting trained by the same
people and they're all trying to come
with me with the same stupid arguments
it's like get be a little bit more
creative guys huh like I love that
you're Public Enemy Number One though
they probably have your face oh for sure
they will nah but I think like the other
water companies some my good friend
always said like Martin be careful when
like you see like some water trucks
maybe they're gonna hijack you one day
there's a lot of money and water they
have that that's the interest in keeping
you quiet yeah
all right let's I'll actually I'm
curious about this water drama now let's
take a look
Jennifer Ketty yup that's it
I'm honestly annoying that I'm even this
video because remember
it's my time how
imagine being so invested in Keegan that
you have to defend the multi-level
business
against an individual probably sold you
a bunch of like
yeah this this is the Mount Rushmore of
water who are you
okay thanks a living off of bashing what
I do for a living so this feels like an
open invitation hello Jennifer Yes
Martin your personal water something you
obviously wanted to hear my voice so I
thought I'm doing a stitch because you
did a stitch as well and thank you so
much for it oh my god dude she's not
ready for them
it's gonna be fun hold on
oh this got some love too on your on
your channel oh yeah it was annoying for
a number of reasons the first being that
his face is just like punch second thing
no
no ma'am he's a handsome man that guy I
was arguing with told me to kill myself
look at that so yeah it's not cool dude
it's not fair it's not fighting Fair
shame on them thank you so much for your
insult that I have a punchable face let
me check with my parents what happened
to my face they are responsible for it
and I will get back to you it's just
been through a sense that like a doctor
is in the background talking also my
friend made this video
um a doctor's in the background talking
and he's just like shaking his head and
making weird eyes like what are you
doing it's a literal doctor a doctor
listen to the video it gets get better
do they does she show the doctor no
absolutely not because I want to see the
doctor no no the doctors actually not
the doctor in his field of that she uh
he is a doctor of I think scientists or
something like this where it's like no
clue what I'm talking about yeah yeah so
it's like classic case of the medium
guys I believe uh have a bunch of
doctors and experts too yeah yeah
like say something but hey I'm here to
answer your question because you had
several questions in your Stitch and the
first one was why I'm not talking and
why making these crazy faces let's face
it I was speechless that a doctor not
even knows the shape of ourselves
reshapes in a new hexagonal form like
the shapes of your cells like I learned
a little message okay wow I mean it's
right a doctor
we can all agree on that yeah hexagonal
cells
yeah maybe in a parallel universe
you absolutely
you know in a parallel universe where
the laws of physics are just totally
different got it right
you have to make it like you have to
talk to the king people like children
yes like two or three old children in
not even a magic school in like
kindergarten to make them somehow
getting what you're trying to say you
have to do it the other way you're
tromblilos one of them said once to me
Martin you're always saying like
alkaline water doesn't make sense
because when it hits your stomach uh the
pH will get naturalized and then he said
by the way Kangen Water gets absorbed by
your body before it hits your stomach
you think what you're the first person
on this planet yeah that's who's able to
absorb water before its stomach hits
it's crazy these people I don't see any
hexagons wow no me neither not not
really even close huh
hexagonal shapes so I don't know what
the doctor is talking about the second
reason is that he's like oh don't buy
Kong and it's an MLM okay
I'm surprised you I'm surprised you had
the courage to come out after that one
we're probably gonna say everyone at the
top makes money and it's a pyramid
scheme so do you know why I have mlms
especially kangan mlms
the magic word and you as a wizard will
love this smell must have a water Wizard
and she calls herself the water wizard
you know horse calls themselves Wizards
clan members well okay
insane not all wizards created equal
accountability when a water company
claims something they better tell the
truth with facts because when they're
not doing it they can get sued so the
problem with the MLM kangan is there is
no accountability for the company for
the mother company in ganik because they
can say our Distributors are doing all
this outrageous videos we don't say
anything about the health claims our
Distributors are saying this so we are
fine so they cannot get sued so that is
for me the big problem with mlms and
especially with kangan there's no
accountability to the mother company
because the health Distributors are
creating these outrageous videos by the
way Mr Mojo was a soil scientist not a
scientist and not even he himself could
replicate his findings what he mentioned
in his books and if Martin would tell me
where he got his is she actually making
money from this I have no clue or she
just like it's it's she's a victim of
theirs oh absolutely they're all victims
yeah and then they are all so deep into
it because they invested so much money
in it that they have to sell it it's
actually it's cruel that's what it is
so sad actually that's that's what the
MLM [__] is correct they sell you a ton
of [__] they fill up your garage and
then you have to sell it yeah and then
at the end of the day you're the only
idiot that actually spent money on it
is that fraud would you say uh roll
he knows a little water sommelier
certificate I will go to the same course
and I will get the same thing because
since that obviously matters or maybe
I'll go on a documentary I don't know
look I'm just a little humble guy who's
passionate about water here even the
United States 2.2 million people don't
have access to clean safe drinking water
and I think we need to change that we
are here on the same page hopefully so
2005 I crafted my first water menu in
Germany because I wanted to bring
attention to water and wanted to bring
more healthy beverages in the restaurant
scene then in 2009 I wrote a book about
water it's called the world of water
it's considered the leading uh book on
this subject of water in Europe then in
2010 I received my certification as a
water summergee from the German water
trade Association by the way I have my
own Academy now it's called the fine
water Academy and I'm certifying water
summer years around the world because
the more we know about water she's out
of her death no she's crazy you might
even say she's waded into the deep end
and is drowned
hey too much water is dangerous huh oh
yeah my mom says you can drown in even a
teaspoon of water
is it better that's for everybody and
then in 2011 I came over to the states
based on the 01 visa for Extraordinary
ability aka the Albert Einstein visa
when you reach the top of your field and
you know
because she's like saying oh he's just a
water somebody who's that guy heard this
random dude on Tick Tock he's saying
yeah maybe I'm a little bit more than
random all right Albert Einstein Visa
who are you again
everything pretty much of your subject
and this was by me with water the US
government can give you a Visa and that
was my entrance to the United States
because I have the One Visa for my
knowledge of water and now I'm just been
featured on hundreds of media Outlets
like the BBC the CNN the Netflix uh
National Geographic that are documentary
as well I think I have slightly just
like a little credibility when it comes
to water but I have a follow-up question
for you so she could not answer she's
refusing to answer this question what I
have for her okay she's still refusing
it let's see then you know what's going
on with it let's see it's when it comes
to Kangen and I would love to know an
explanation what medical device actually
means under the Japanese law because I
see a lot of Kenyan people using this as
a defense of like look this is a medical
device so again what is this entails
actually another Japanese law to be a
medical device is that what they're
saying in Japan they can correct so so
Kangen always or this Distributors
always saying but it's a medical device
water a medical device so I looked into
it because I like to fact check my stuff
so medical device under the Japanese law
means it will not blow up in your face
it's safe to use so for example a glove
is a medical device a Band-Aid is a
medical device it has no meaning
whatsoever for any health aspects even
under the Japanese law they're forbidden
to say ionizing machines are forbidden
to claim any health aspects but in
America they're claiming oh it's a
medical device water therefore it's so
amazing what they say in Japan
in Japan it's considered a medical
device but again it's just but medical
device just means no safe in this
operation there's nothing else no health
benefits that is very weird sneaky
sneaky okay answer the question then
lady
would love to know that the cancer
surviving
human so what I say doesn't mean
anything either Jennifer hopefully sorry
you had cancer but no it doesn't it
doesn't
it's in Spanish I can't survive as
something as a pro on subjects of water
I mean I don't know my mother is a
cancer survive and what I'm saying it in
a second she's a cancer survive and I'm
very happy she listened to doctors
another water company okay yeah
as a cancer survivor I believe I'm
entitled to uh tell you about the
physics of nuclear reactors
as you see
it's implanted some kind of wisdom in my
brain I like you a little bit warm
against mlms and why I'm against Kangen
water but I wanted to say something very
personal to you because I know that
you're a cancer survivor and I want to
congratulate on that because you have to
be a very strong and powerful woman to
fight cancer and you did it and I'm so
happy for you that you did that my
mother's second Survivor as well she had
breast cancer for 40 years ago and I'm
so happy like her that you went to
doctors that you got treatment and I
know how shamrotherapy how hard it is
and to get an operation and you did not
listen to mumbo jumbo claims on the
internet that you can heal your cancer
by drinking a special water so thank you
so much for that and all the best to you
Jennifer and remember water it's not
just water yes we won't forget
what a great video
so she she she erased her video yeah
sure she erased the video and then she
started to text me on Instagram and I
was I was a nice guy and I said like so
can you please answer my question and
then she suddenly played the victim card
like I don't feel comfortable that your
fans now texting me and harassing me
saying sweetie you started that whole
thing huh yeah like I'm so sorry she
started by calling your face pawn shop
yeah I'm like that's like so low listen
you actually made a reasonable response
I think so too so is her video still up
on Instagram
she's out
she deleted he's welcome to call into
the show
yeah please Canyon people huh come over
to H3 podcast we will have some fun with
them oh yeah okay well I'm glad that
that's a dub for the water small yeah of
course it would be
so um
what what's our what's the schedule
there Sam
we got the place she's got a bunch of
stuff there to get started how do you
want to show off some flavors there
should we get started with our beverages
all right probably show some oh yeah let
me watch some videos water talks so what
is water talk
um so there's a new trend on Tick Tock
it's very popular water talk people
share their recipes
for water
which is interesting I thought it was
just one ingredient
oh that's not true though there's men
correct there's a little bit more but I
think like the recipe for water is
created by Nature that's my belief it's
all H H2O yeah that's the recipe of
water plus minerals essentially all
they're doing is dumping huge amounts of
sugar into the water or in most cases
it's artificial sweetener
uh claiming it's water so here's some
examples of popular water talks pina
colada water
now this is a popular recipe it has
300 000 likes
so I'm assuming it's got at least a
million uh reviews yeah yeah
so here it is oh she also has a code
here use Tonya 42 to save money
awesome water of the day and it is 11 55
so I'm cruising with the water girls
today let's go to the old caddy these
are my favorites down here so I'm just
gonna pick one not even gonna look this
is giving me like Facebook live totally
[Laughter]
did any of you guys ever watch that
[__] there were so many people once you
go down that rabbit hole of like they're
streaming themselves like opening pearls
opening oysters and then selling the
pearls some of them make jewelry out of
it and like some of it was so obviously
fake or like weird it was very weird
they buy the oysters pre-slotted with
the pearls from like uh Southeast Asian
countries that just like super
unethically
Farm them and just shove like Earl's ah
it's super weird dude but yeah this is
giving me this
you know see what are we gonna get
oh crushed pineapple one of my face what
we're gonna add it with all right let's
go to the Water Bar What's it gonna be
y'all what dragon fruit
coconut let's do that two pumps well
that was a coconut syrup mom's trying to
have a pina colada let's do three all
right pineapple packets
I literally cannot wait to open that
simple modern cup it's 40 ounces Also
let's give this a go that looks like my
pee
with all the ice cubes
not that yet I'm sorry I'm better
hydrated you're right oh my God
and I do baby
let's give this a go
she loved it
if you like pina colada what can I do
baby she didn't really say if it was
good or not I mean she started dancing
so kind of she filmed that it's good
really shocked by all the sweetness so
so what's interesting is the pumping of
syrup and the powders
what's interesting to me is they they're
acting like they're doing something new
but they're isn't it just juice just
they're creating sodas non-carbonated
soda that's all that is it's just with a
high possibility of diabetes too in the
future right that's all what that is so
I should say
a lot of these hashtags about weight
loss and stuff so I guess a lot of it is
about getting off sugar
um
right really yeah but this artificial
sweetest are not really healthier let's
say like that
conversation we would like to have
Martin I have news for you
know Dr IDs
he's a prolific Tick-Tock doctor okay
and he's been on the show to debate that
very topic he he claims artificial
sweeteners have been proven
to be uh uh there's no proof that
they're harmful let's say that he's
calling in later to report on a study
put out by the World Health Organization
not a study a statement saying don't
drink artificial sweeteners
so we're gonna have the chance to cross
over Bridgewater sommelier oh I'm happy
to learn as well
he is unlike the Keegan doctor a highly
qualified medical researcher
demand
so if he's what what my problem is with
artificial sweetener it gives me this
extremely dry mouth feel and when you
drink a little bit more than all this
like Diet stuff it it's super strange on
your palette at one point and it almost
feels like you need more and more and
more and more and I think that has
something to do maybe with like because
I have it with some borders when I'm
coming from natural cream sauce when
they're super lone TDS they're pulling
minerality of your saliva and then you
have this dry mouth here this is like
the thing was tazani that everybody
thinks dazani adds salt because they
want to make you thirstier actually
that's not true that's a myth yes
they're adding salt but in very small
amounts like the TDS of design is 28
it's like barely anything in there
they're not adding enough salt to make
that actually taste and I think that is
the problem what I have with this
artificial sweeteners that they're
giving this strange weird dry mouth feel
after a while and it's this and for me
it's disgusting okay and there it is
there it is
I don't think so to uh let's face it
like when they they're saying like
artificially flavored or natural flavor
let's let's just like in my opinion it's
almost [__] well our natural natural
versus artificial flavors of course
whoops let's face it uh even when it
says natural flavor that does not mean
there's like real lemon juice or
something in there no they're finding a
chemical what's been found in nature
they're putting this processing this
highly in a lab and like it's barely
anything different between artificial
and natural flavor it's a marketing
chemical well can I ask you something
there I've so there's stuff like uh monk
fruit what is it called monk fruit
sweetener and it's like
it's an artificial sweetener there's no
calories
but it makes things sweet and it's I
guess made from granulated monk fruit is
that right then are you seeing anything
on that I am I've never I've never
actually heard of it so so I actually
heard about that from another doctor on
Tick Tock I follow a lot of these
medical guys and he says
he um eats Greek yogurt with monk monk
fruit sweetener that's the one he uses
what are you reading about it how is it
made uh what are monk fruits sweeteners
monk fruit also known as a
okay I'm not going to say hello
Google bro you seriously just butchered
I'm trying uh or swingle fruit I like
swingle fruit that's just funny small
round fruit native to Southern China
monk fruit sweeteners are no calorie
sweeteners that can be used to lowers
one intake of added sugars uh while
still providing a satisfaction to enjoy
or taste something isn't that
interesting it just comes from this
is that so weird I've never heard of
this it makes it sweet but there's no
sugar there's no calories
and it's the same thing with uh uh
zetiva how do you call it sativa no no
Stevia
what do you think about Steve yeah
again it gives me all this weird weird
aftertaste what is this This Is War uh
what do you think about War uh this guy
your thoughts he feels a little
dehydrated
yeah he's not looking very healthy like
wait what the [__] did I type yeah I
think oh yeah I don't know Evia
okay here stevia plant
select the monk fruit it comes from this
plant and I don't know how it's
processed
Stevia causes a causes what's called
depression and what is called the
depression
back up horses
what what do you mean what's called
depression I I said courses oh it causes
depression and even Dr Ritz agrees with
that I found a tick tock where he agrees
oh all right hold your cards well I was
ready I've been I've been load and did
oh oh love is ready to debate doctor is
love is very much on your side Martin
yeah he's not a believer in the
artificial sweeteners and yeah we need
them I am
I'm a hardcore
Coke Zero guy you used to be Pepsi Max
huh right did you know that they got rid
of it
I know stuff it's a deep one yeah
I used to live in Israel Pepsi Max was
the thing for us it was very popular I
don't know maybe it still is there I'm
not sure should go to Israel again four
years ago it was oh yeah vacations ever
oh cool Tel Aviv oh my God love that
City yeah me too so much fun
well Ethan and I years ago back in
Israel we kind of used to argue about
that because he would always drink
the diet drinks and I used to feel like
I have a feeling they're not good for
you and he would be like well there's no
study that is calories there's zero
calories and I always said well I just
have a feeling that something doesn't
add up I mean it's just the laws of
thermodynamics zero calories that's it
right there's yeah what does zero Kelly
says about should be exactly there's a
very famous brand it's called I think
Vitamin Water
120 calories that's just good I don't
drink I have no clue how they even
allowed to call themselves I agree right
[__]
non-carbonated soda pop I totally for
the for the people who hate me on this
now yes they have the zero ones as well
yeah but it not even looks like water
huh dragon fruit is not water yes there
it is it's a soda full sabotaging Martin
is taking his hand but I agree on the
the vitamin water is tricky I mean
that's just a flavored drink yeah it's
absolutely drink it's a candy
oh let's move it on to um lemon pound
cake water
sounds good to me
and I believe Sam prepared us this one
is that right yes we have that one on
standby so take a look at this and let
us know what you think also you can go
ahead and just bring it on outside I
will note that all these ladies it seems
to be mostly ladies doing it all have
coupon codes and [__] in their
description
for 10 off your first order of skinny
mixes
use the code water gal 10.
another flavored water sleigh let's go
so I just got home from work okay I'm a
fan
flavored water slate time well it's
rocking my big natural hair and now it's
time for us to make my final water of
the day so today's water is going to be
inspired by one of my all-time favorite
desserts a lemon pound cake to get
started grab your favorite 40 ounce cup
I'm not using my Stanley today because I
got a clear cup for you so that you can
see the drink fill it up with about 35
ounces of water and five ounces of ice
but to be honest today I just kind of
wing it so do whatever you want okay so
for the powders we're gonna start by
using one lemonade packet I got mine
from HEB but anyway I got mine from
skinnygal.com coupon code skinnyten
grenade pocket will do and now for this
it's just it's honestly giving me more
than anything multi-level marketing yeah
yeah get the cake flavor you're going to
be using vanilla almond
two and I I can't get behind the syrup
pumping that to me that's scary yeah
yeah
his hat is syrup implies there's
something else in it to make it thick
okay and can I just point out
the first ingredient is a lemonade
packet at this point you're just
drinking lemonade right that's what I
don't understand nothing to do with it
like we were just oh we've already
before you add anything else you you put
the lemonade packet in there that that's
lemonade no it's one recipe I don't know
what you're talking about
water recipes stop it semen tastes good
oh no okay that's a difference that's
not a water
I love the delusion I know
as well
I love everything maybe maybe maybe
drinking it makes their eyes bold
right yeah hello I have some water with
me
wow
it causes like hyperthyroidism
this water has a flavor profile it's
wild hold on girl I'm not putting butter
in my water girl have you ever tried it
though okay I'm about to is this the
same recipe Sam yes really exciting I
don't know if this is exciting
We Got The Buttery let me finish let me
finish
oh my God and a half pumps of caramel
into the cup all right you know the
drill we're gonna mix mix until all of
that powder is dissolved okay so I went
ahead and I put the lid on and now it's
time for the taste test
whoa yeah whoa it's so bad
[Laughter]
whoa that's my reaction when I have a
very bad water whoa
it's really good it's light it's
refreshing it's perfect for summer it
just has that little hint of decadent
look disgusting just a hint the hint of
disgusting okay so I've wondered how
sweet are these drinks oh my gosh and
now we get to find out so cheers
it's Friday
okay be brave Martin I know there are
sacrifices
that is so sweet the smell already
I knew these women weren't right
I'm not exaggerating I hate it it is so
[__] sweet
I hate the battery like the fact that I
heard her say buttery and now I can
taste it and you know what it tastes
like Ela remember when we tried those
disgusting weird flavor sodas like baked
yes oh yes that's the uh Justin Bieber
totally even the color it looks like it
so as I suspected it is like
insanely sweet and just vile lemony
butter
but interesting enough as well the first
video in the second video they first of
all they're saying water so obviously
they're using I think tap water it
doesn't matter actually what kind of
water they're using because they have
they're bloating it in with all this
crap and therefore it doesn't matter how
good the water is in the beginning
because you're getting rid of all the
[__]
um and then they're adding tons of ice
cubes did you saw this both videos are
like tons of ice cubes in there they
have to you're anti-ice yeah because
imagine this lukewarm you're gonna puke
video where I tasted
Logan Paul's Prime energy drinks okay
I had almost a heart attack it was one
of my worst tastings ever in my life and
I cannot believe the hype after that I
could not believe it I tasted it and
again it's so sweet it's so disgusting I
agree with you I I dumped it has like a
thousand views I dumped that whole thing
in my like no but people but Olivia is
feeling good I can't even believe what
I'm hearing right now I I really like it
too prime it is I will drink that as
water
what did you think I was watching I saw
you I saw you hold on get really mad at
me hold on guys everybody calm down okay
okay Martin I believe you guys
really
come on I know it's almost a year that I
was here huh like we need to we need to
have a private discussion I think okay
set aside the time absolutely and I was
watching your reaction though you did
not I didn't like that it tasted milky
yeah can I say sorry holy [__] no don't
say that it's about to do it oh my God
no it's not that bad
no way I don't think it's water listen
it's not water but The Buttery flavor
crazy ass it's super sweet but yeah
that's not bad you like the butter
flavor in your water Dan
it's buttery it's light
I will I definitely would not describe
it as light but
not refreshing come on that is not
refreshing Martin what flavor of prime
did you try I had all three which I have
like I have no clue what they call it
because I erased some right away out of
my brain did you try the one that was
red white and blue on this same bottle
no no I had the energy drinks of prime
okay well you know what Martin we're
gonna have a little a little girl's day
and you're gonna try the hydration
okay we'll see I had a new right story I
know that and I had no clue what Brew
raspberry is natural flavor blue
raspberry since when a raspberry is blue
natural flavor when they grow they're
blue
uh-huh under a lot of like different
like yeah they're neon but you had a lot
of other drugs maybe priorities might be
blue yeah I have to defend my ice water
though I'm a water person I drink water
all day
and coffee but I like my waterway dice
it's fine it's so good when you like it
but it's I'm against the idea of that a
restaurant serves you automatically ice
and lemon in your water that is my
problem
when I'm buying myself for 12 or 13 a
bottle of water in a restaurant and a
fancy one and you know you've been to
this yes the restaurant where I did the
Stitch with by the way I gotta invite
you to my restaurant where I'm working
currently at Grand in Los Angeles on
Sunset Boulevard and I want to see a
full rough review what you're doing over
there so on Sunset Boulevard with Curtis
Stone come over you're invited it's a
nice beautiful Mission All Star
Restaurant really yeah it's a nice date
night huh okay there it is blue
raspberries what
because I was curious because there's
other blue raspberry things and I I
don't know why
Logan Paul's a Creator he's he's
colorblind I think so maybe
he thinks he's like a freaking blueberry
but let's go on because okay it has to
be like the worst already so let's see
what else is
before Dan came here and said he liked
it I wanted to go back and watch her
reaction again
little hint of decadence tasting it I
can't stand that
whoa whoa hello
Dan you I can't believe you just did
that
go out of my way to drink this but no no
no I wouldn't say it's Martin I am so
sorry I talked to them beforehand
I I'm a I respect water I love water I
got the I got the shower filter that you
recommended last time you were here I've
been here since it's fantastic Martin
that that filter changed my life it
changed am I made my hair so much more
silky I don't have that problem
better now since you use the shower
filter
I will say I wasn't able to use it
because it doesn't fit on our shower
head
I use the other one are you serious
you've been using the other one the
whole time oh yeah oh yeah
it's got the filter oh we got the filter
yep you don't even use that no
wow you know they have a whole
filtration system for your house
[Music]
I bought a house in Van Nuys and I'm
super excited they just shipped it to me
and I gotta do that because that's gonna
be
changing for everything where do I buy
it on their website a bigger unit
correct it's a unit and then you're done
and then that whole house has perfect
water
let's do that
there it is Martin knows what he's
talking about oh people are asking about
the filter again what was it called
again Martin
and then there's another
was I I was
I was about coffee
and I wanted to see if my coffee will
change because let's face it coffee is
98 water yeah so then it's actually a
flavored water coffee water talk here we
go
you can do now Coffee Talk
um so I used a lag filter it's pretty
cool l-a-r-q spelled correct a large
filter okay I put my tap water in there
and then I brewed like with an espresso
machine because I wanted to make sure
it's exactly the same coffee so I use
the same pots I use the same press
button so I used tap water unfiltered
and then the lag filtered water and you
should see the picture like I have it on
my on my Tick Tock it's night and day
it's the color is completely different
really like the filtered water the
coffee was so alive all the rumors of
your coffee came alive it looked great
it tasted great and with the unfiltered
tap it was disgusting it was completely
hitting the flavors it was super bitter
and weird and even the color was
different I want to see unbelievable yo
how different a coffee will taste just
by a good water you know when we ate
hummus in our favorite place in Israel
we asked them about like why is it so
different overseas always and they said
it's all the way
they're full of [__] they just don't
want to tell you what they do New York
Bagels are different yeah because of the
water there's no shot by the way and
I'll say it too hold on and I'll say
this there are hummus places that we
found that are as good in L.A there's
not many there's one or two maybe we
have a filter system please uh in Israel
okay maybe maybe the water maybe
I don't know but at least like that
they're filling out
although I think to replicate Israel
they need to add [__] yeah you need to
make it dirty yeah
a little bit of like uranium it will
just tear on a little bit of dirt a
little Anthrax I don't know
but um so if I get that big house filter
will that make my coffee like way better
oh my God I'm sold Lena can you remind
us
yeah oh yeah we're doing that
[__] yeah congratulations on your house
by the way you bought a house recently
oh I'm so happy that's huge thank you
it's a big commitment and then I thought
like I have solo on the roof and I
thought okay Martin you want to be a
little bit more conscious about the
environment so I bought my first
electric carner as well since four days
a car a car it's a taikon yep oh hell
yeah that's what I'm driving look I love
Porsche oh my God Martin you're stacked
how come you are what no but like what's
your can you tell me about like
your income sources
I mean you're stacked I'm a hydrated guy
yeah
no he's stacked I'm working full time at
the ssgm at Curtis Stone's restaurant
yeah so when you when you want to see me
or meet me come to Gwen so what is this
position there water assuming I'm the
general manager of that restaurant oh
general manager the GM really why don't
we go there
say hi to Martin the whole team maybe oh
my God there's a private dining area
upstairs that would be awesome oh okay
we're doing that town huh like we have
like we're doing like and everything we
have our own butcher shop as well [__]
Dave and Busters
we all just went to Dave and Busters
Martin does your does your restaurant
have any um like carnival games video
games
[Applause]
that you're happy
I wish restaurants with dress code oh I
mean reviews
oh wait this is the chef the Australian
Top Chef Guy correct oh I recognize him
oh he's a famous chef oh yeah yeah right
wow does he work there like regular yeah
he's all the time there oh my God
you're bawling at it you got a high
level wow
last time last time we were here you
rolled up in the most bitching 911 I've
ever seen I still have it don't worry
that's okay you're the man yo we got to
go to Gwen okay okay I see what's going
on here great restaurant what kind of
food is it
I don't want to say it's really a
steakhouse but it's like a butcher shop
and obviously heavily on stake so like
dry aging 80 days 30 days okay like it's
really really nice oh let's go let's go
next week let's go for the water or I
mean I don't want to say when we'll be
there but yeah not next week
not next Friday at 7pm do we need to
make a resume yeah always let me know
how far a week a week events is always
helpful so what let's talk we'll talk
about it how nice right okay
um so let's try Dr IDs is going to call
in soon let's try some more uh Waters
okay
what isn't the fun couple uh Sam over
there
it's the next one that's highlighted why
don't we skip to that special recipe
yeah
all right here we go this fashionable
one yeah this one's very special I have
a very special bonus of all for you guys
okay thank you oh this is the new cup we
heard about this is the new Cup oh it's
so pretty cool thank you all right here
we go all right y'all we're back for
another water here we go we got our
store first
painter again which I'm super excited to
try so we're going to put that can I
point something out Dan tell me if I can
say this oh boy
I'm not I think
do you get it I think like I have a
feeling yeah that would be a no Ethan
speak before Dan reads it
yeah no definitely you got a hard note
from everybody because everyone knows
what I was gonna say though right of
course I really didn't know whether you
were going with that but you really
don't even need to say you don't think
that's a good observation no no it's a
terrible one I'll tell you what I should
just say it I'm gonna say something I
don't
probably shouldn't say ing
I know someone had a similar observation
fun cup everybody I feel like that's
what Dan's typing
like oh yeah that is so much guys all
right let's watch
let's watch
bottle here and we're gonna shake it up
here we go we'll be ready oh I like the
color all right and we're back
we're gonna put it in our water
we're gonna be adding strawberries okay
so it's like a martini she's mixing it
in a plastic bottle and then pouring it
in this is interesting I think it's
super tropical
now you know what's wrong with my
podcast
s right what will cause foam and water
like that I don't even want to know
why is it foaming
look at that it's like beach it's like
ocean current yeah the ocean is uh very
pure right semen
the ocean has a tedious of 38 000. well
can I make a point I wouldn't drink that
if you think about it ocean is just a
flavor of water it's so true that is so
true salt
now you know what's wrong with our pumps
don't make fun of me go check my Elastic
Girl those pumps are embarrassing
I don't know why those pumps are like
really aggressive looking oh yeah they
they pump
yeah they're not cute huge bumps in here
we're gonna do one
one two two people that was three
wait honestly we saw what you did kind
of like a snow cone which I'm I'm
interested in yeah yeah but nope yeah
but people don't be like I'm thirsty let
me eat a snow cone basically water
people on Tick Tock are doing that okay
they do be doing that
one strawberry maybe two oh
all right we got our straw all right
look how pretty she is
she said she's gonna make it tropical
and she added Peach and strawberry
neither of those are tropical fruits uh
it's a nice tropical maybe together they
are Maybe
what flavors is Pink Pink Starburst
like the candy really that's the name of
it yeah no it's it's start it's perfect
and we have it that's what is in our Cup
right now
oh my God you guys
Starburst packets
I kind of believe that I'm drinking oh
my goodness let me know what you guys
made today in the comments dude I'm
saying is this good or bad huh yeah
she's like I'm shocked what I just
created
Cheers Cheers
that is so [__] sweet
IE why did they do that
I'm so upset oh no oh Martin no Martin
aborted
[Music]
that's what the flavor is and insult on
your palette
I got a lot of disappointment flavors
from that
well you have this you have this really
sensitive palette dissect that those
flavors for us if you can describe it in
a sommelier
that's interesting
Coca-Cola created this Stardust Coke I
think a special edition last year that
tastes slightly similar to that we have
one over burnt cotton candy yeah we
weren't that's what that taste is
overburned cotton candy when when when
you're going to your fair and there's
like a guy who's like not doing would
not know what to do with this
such a bad flavor in my mouth
now Sam did you do the um the larger
portion of the sweetener like she did
okay yeah yeah that's disgusting here we
go shame on you
if you're drinking that whole thing
that's that's wild that's a 10. that is
the sweetest thing I've ever done holy
[__] and now imagine it's when it's warm
because the flavor will even gain and we
warm it up
and then it's like hardcore because what
it does when you're adding too much eye
oil when you're adding super much ice
boil that for me you are hiding the
flavors because you're kind of like
numbing up a little bit your palette by
the ice cubes you put 100 yeah so
one of the worst things you ever put in
your mouth
that's why an I talk even about the
three girls on Van Nuys Boulevard this
is so this one is really
lingering so yes it's lingering
lingering I mean just imagine intensely
intensely artificial sweetener just the
Mac in you in the face man
but let's see her reaction to the flavor
again I find this interesting oh my gosh
yeah that's kind of similar to your
reaction Mommy
foreign
like what the hell did I do you could
tell in her eyes right now like I
completely [__] up you said Sam has
all the flavors yeah if you want to make
one of your own but look at that like
it's clearly this this impression of oh
my God it's so bad how are you gonna
like save this video now now Mark one
tool no no stuff Martin Sam warmed this
up for me in the microwave
the pink Drink enjoy
it's still like lukewarm room temp oh
that's [__] nasty
it's like acid oh I don't have something
I mean I don't think you're sick but I
will not share with you anyway you don't
want any of this nobody else wants to
hit this almost boiling
sugar water or not sugar water
sugar-free water
you know in a sense though do is there
any other ones we should try before uh
those were we were gonna make our own
those were the only two like existing
formulas that we made you get the idea
but I will say it is um I have um
hold on what about doc what about
Mountain Dew water
same water I made yesterday why because
it's that good now my theory on this
Martin tell me what you think
water if this is making them drink more
water quote unquote if you can call it
that then maybe it's a net good for them
if they're trying to lose weight trying
to go back on sugary drinks if there's
no sugar in it I mean I think they're
going way too far with the amount of
sweetener in it but in a sense good for
them they're drinking more fluid I think
like my take is on it because again I
think 95 of Americans still think water
is just water and it's all the same
again they have flavors in water already
where you can already get all this
amazing flavor from nature with zero
sweeteners zero calories there's nothing
artificially added just healthy great
amazing minerals slash electrolytes so I
believe in that well okay so I think for
people like look last time I brought
vegetalan for example what has a clearly
distinct flavor like this slightly
saltiness I think for people who want to
get rid of their soda consumption look
for really cool amazing spring sourced
Waters with a higher TDS level and you
will be amazed that these Waters
actually have great taste you don't need
to add all this crap to it so Martin can
you tell me which spring will produce me
Mountain Dew water if you love it's
heart water then this one's for you if
you don't love its heart water then I've
got 100 other recipes for it all right
let's get let's get Dr IDs on the phone
all right oh yeah you like that color
that will glow all right so now
we're bringing doc I'm gonna do a quick
bathroom break alrighty too much water
should have spit it out he was stuck uh
all right
Dr IDs here we are joined
by the great illustrious
celebrated
the uh Dr IDs
[Applause]
I I understand you were enjoying a
little vacation uh
out in Morocco is that right
yes no Morocco was fantastic yeah I had
a really really nice time I'm glad you
enjoyed you deserved the break I mean my
God doctor is working Round the Clock
thank you my friend thank you how are
you Ethan how are you I'm very good I'm
actually really happy to talk to you
because I've been catching a lot of [__]
from these haters in the office because
of this outrageous
claim put out by the World Health
Organization now but I want to introduce
you first of all because we do have
someone else here Martin the water
sommelier he's also a tick tock
personality are you aware of Martin this
water sommelier
no no I haven't seen Martin nice it's a
pleasure good to meet you my friend
great guy you both are great guys here
but uh he's he's a water expert a water
smallier really a thing and he knows his
stuff so
he's here to uh share in this uh
conversation of great importance that's
great more the more people involved the
better the water Symposium uh the doctor
doctor carnivore is yet still to uh
respond to her yeah
um
a model from Carnival he's taken
Carnival out of his handle now what is
it now it's now it's now just Paul
saladino Paul saladino give me a break
loser idiot
hey uh doctors before we get started are
you still single what's going on with
the dating life
I am yes I haven't found uh well the
women are out there clamoring you know
what I mean what city do you live in
I'm from the West Midlands in the UK
West Air oh a shout out West Midlands
yes yes
pick up the West mids
and would your significant other are you
looking for someone who shares your kind
of Faith background yeah yeah yeah so
there you go so if there's any uh Dr IDs
is looking he's eligible he's a doctor
for God's sake exercises
we gotta you know what I mean let us
know okay
thank you my friend thank you my friend
Ethan you're sounding uh under the
weather are you okay no
no I'm not I have it my throat's [__]
up yeah hello but also doctor would you
be happy to know I don't know if you
noticed but I lost a lot of weight since
we last talked
you're doing very well my friend very
well excellent good work drinking lots
of water
for saying that nice to meet you
yeah this is the first time right yeah
I've been on several times yeah it's
okay so this is a great meeting of mine
yeah
okay so let's talk shop here doctor
I think me and uh me and love have some
unfinished business clears yes how did
you know
I just know if there was one person in
the crew to uh kind of do a fist bump to
like the who guidelines is probably love
oh you're right actually I think I think
love even prepared some questions for
you
you kind of just came on and I had an
opinion I shared it this time I kind of
prepared a little bit and should I go
straight into it
this the World Health Organization who
by the way is full of quacks and
charlton's this this organization can't
be trusted just on its face I mean the
way they filled the world during covid
basically legitimize them forever but
okay here they come World Health
Organization warns against using
artificial sweeteners now I read this
and I says here we go maybe maybe this
is the Breakthrough that we've all been
dreading right and doctor is you
mentioned you don't drink plain water
right you don't [__] with water
that's what I said that's what he drinks
this man lives on yellow drinks oh my
God this is why I'm watching that's what
I said Doctor it's he lives but he
doesn't just preach it this man lives it
and his wife he has a beautiful mind too
what is that yellow what is the yellow
drink
I will down the whole thing right now if
I have to just to show you that it's
safe anyway no I believe you he had the
same thing last time I asked him it's
basically I don't know if you guys have
it it's it's Robinson's brand is is a
brand of squash it's like a very
concentrated
you know solution you add to water so
it'll be this much water
and then there'll be a tiny bit at the
top of the of the yellow drink that I
add let yell loved yellow drink this man
does not drink water Martin he does
doesn't do it there are some people out
there our former Chancellor smoked for
80 years I think and he I think he
turned like 95 when he passed some other
people dying on cancer when they're
snake smoking so I think it's a it's I
think every human person has a different
like synopsis of what's good and what's
bad for them and I've personally for me
as a water so Maggie I think in general
it's healthier to drink
real water versus water with sweetener
or with stuff in there for the most of
the population let's say it like that
this is the debate we're having it's a
great debate and I love that Dr IDs
lives it you know what I mean that's my
man right there I'm not just saying it
he lives it so back to the Health
Organization this corrupt organization
that should be disbanded
um they put up the statement and I was
like oh no and I read the [__]
article I start reading it and I'm like
hold the phone what if they're not
saying anything new they're literally
just saying super General
weird [__] like they go uh let's see
they say these alternatives to sugar
when consumed do not reduce serve to
reduce body fat and either adults or
children well nobody was claiming that
right doctor Ethan you missed you missed
the two key words in that sentence
long term long term yes oh yeah my bad
when consumed long term yeah
yeah so what was your take on this big
press release by the by the corruption
and uh a big submerged World Health
Organization
so so basically hey funny funny little
uh anecdote first so I'm actually on the
um who fighties Committee of health
professionals that combat misinformation
online uh-oh right and the funny thing
is the funny thing is is that it's now
my duty to correct the who oh really I
knew it you all I said wait till Dr is
calls in we're gonna put this whole
thing to rest you can tell which side of
the thing I fall on okay oh yeah so I
have a vested interest go ahead
let me just start off by saying that did
anyone read or look through the 90-page
PDF guideline that they actually
released oh no
okay so so that would be a good start
first of all I because I'm obviously
interested in the science so I obviously
went through it in pretty good detail
and now let me point out that
technically what they're saying based on
the total body of evidence is their main
statement is that going from sugary
drinks to low calorie drinks whether you
sweeteners doesn't seem to induce
long-term weight loss now the key point
there is long term there are several
reasons for this number one
the controlled human studies that we
have on this topic there aren't many
that go beyond one year anyway right so
they're mostly conducted three month
period six month period I've actually
got papers that I that I that I'm going
to show you guys with the graphs and
what the results actually show so I've
got two studies that I want to show you
excellent
um the second thing I would say is
the long-term evidence we have in humans
are what we call observational evidence
or cohort studies and what this means is
you don't actually give the intervention
to a group of people you take a group of
people in the population and You observe
them you don't interfere with their
habits at all right and then you take
the group that consumes sweeteners and
you compare them to the group that
doesn't consume sweeteners right so if
you look at in the US you take a random
hundred thousand people right let's say
30 000 of them consume artificial
sweeteners can any of you tell me what
type of person would typically consume
artificial sweeteners
the fatties
yeah
yeah exactly exactly right so it's
typically so because all of these drinks
and all of these products are framed as
diet drinks right Diet Coke these habits
are going to be employed by people that
want to go on a diet right so when you
look at those people who consume
sweeteners on average are they going to
be fatter than those who don't yes
right so we haven't we have an issue of
what we call reverse causality it's not
that the sweeteners are causing the
fatness is that the fatness are leading
people to consume more sweeteners right
yeah right so that that's the second
thing is that because we don't have
controlled studies
that last over a period of years we have
to look at observational data and even
they in their 90 page PDF they address
that there is a possible issue of
reverse causality right so that's the
second thing now their statement is a
little bit misleading to people who
aren't in the academic field because
people who aren't aren't actually
conducting research might not understand
that the key phrasing is because we
don't have the controlled research over
a long period of time
but let me show you something am I able
to share my screen oh yeah I think so oh
yeah I think so yeah Dan's gone I've got
a yeah I've got it here
oh no okay yeah let me just uh we'll
give you access but another thing as you
pull that up they don't say
that artificial sweeteners are unhealthy
no no actually if you looked at the
guidelines they actually state that
these recommendations are for people
without pre-existing diabetes or insulin
resistance so actually what they're
assuming is that their recommendation
doesn't apply to diabetes so by
definition the recommendation to consume
them in diabetes is still valid right
what they're saying is in a population
that are completely healthy
metabolically healthy they don't think
that there's enough evidence to make the
conclusion that you should switch from
sugars to low calorie drinks and that's
the key point in which I would disagree
strongly on that's and I will show you
that seems like a crazy
stands yes yes I would say so I would
say so so I would too
so this is the so do you guys see this
yes we do okay okay now
this is all quite complicated jargon
I'll just quickly run through it okay
this is what we call a meta-analysis
study so this title here this is a
meta-analysis what that means is it is a
study of studies so where researchers
take a question and they look at a lot
of the research papers that have been
done and they analyze multiple studies
at the same time to try and reach a
conclusion right so think of it as a big
research study okay
they took 17
individual randomized controlled human
trials so 17 individual studies on this
topic
and they looked at what happens when you
switch and you substitute between sugar
sweetened beverages that's SSB here
low calorie or no calorie sugar sweet uh
sugary drinks and you all water right so
they looked at what happens when you go
from sugar low calorie or water okay now
let me get up the tables here so do you
guys see this table here yes
okay now so this table
is showing what happens
when you go from
oh sorry this table shows what happens
when you go from sugary drinks here on
the right hand side
to the low calorie drinks here so see
this column where you've got the little
the kind of um
where it says favors sugary drinks and
favors low calorie if you look at all of
the metrics they tested they tested body
weight on the left here BMI here body
fat here they looked at glycemic markers
hpa1c they looked at insulin resistance
they looked at even blood lipids LDL
non-hdrc triglycerides they looked at
blood pressure they looked at liver
markers liver enzymes right if you see
here pretty much all of them favor the
low calorie drink
and this these are results from 17
randomized controlled human trials okay
so now we have to be careful that
because you see these lines we can only
say that it's statistically significant
if both sides of the line fall beyond
the left side of this dotted line here
so the ones that are significant are
this one that's body fat that's BMI
that's body weight we have this one here
that that's a liver marker and we have
these ones that are almost significant
blood pressure right and pretty much the
rest of them we see Trends towards
improvements when you go from sugars to
low calorie drinks so we come down here
and we look at now what happens when you
go from sugary drinks to water right
depending on Mark so whatever Martin's
view was and also love you would
probably have said this but if people
went from sugary drinks to water they
should see an even greater Improvement
in health I don't see that yeah you
don't see it not there so it's not even
as good so it's trending it's not even
as good yeah yeah it's trending but look
at it compared to the look at it
compared to the low calorie diet that
one's performing better how did you
explain that I think everybody agrees
cutting the sugars right like well well
yes but that what Dr is is saying that
their statement said they can't even say
for certainty that going from sugared to
artificial sweeteners is recommended
which is insane yeah yeah now now let me
show you the third let me show you the
third graph okay this is this is
comparing
uh uh low calorie drinks with water okay
pretty much all they're they're pretty
much all of them are slap bang in the
Middle with low calorie drinks showing a
benefit for systolic blood pressure
compared to water that's huge how can it
be hold on hold on hold on hold on
it's better now let it the man speak
let me cook let me cook it all right now
this control trial is a perfect example
here in 2016. the beta 3 300 weight
stable people that were overweight or
obese okay they were told they were
given the intervention to consume 700 mL
of water or low calorie drink like I'm
drinking right now every day for one
year okay they did that every day for
one year now look at this
this is this is going up in weeks okay
this is the
um percent body weight change minus one
percent minus two minus three minus four
the bottom line the more drastic line is
the low calorie group
compared to the water who lost only a
third of the same weight so the water
group lost two kilograms the low calorie
group the low calorie drinks lost more
than six kilograms over the one year hmm
so when you compare water to low calorie
drinks you lose even more weight going
to the low calorie drinks can I ask you
something how
you should know you should know you've
seen enough of my videos I know every
it's because it satisfies your uh your
desire to eat those different things
yeah but that's exactly but doctor is
let me ask you because I I do drink
water a lot but I do also crave sweets a
lot and I eat a bunch sometimes I hit it
to Coke Zero and it's good and I'm good
instead of eating a chocolate or
something but doctors let me ask you
yeah
if
the results are so obvious yeah how did
they get this so wrong
so no no they haven't got it wrong
they're technically correct that's why
I'm trying to the language they use is
important they never denied they never
denied that in the short term going from
sugars to low calorie drinks provides
benefits in in body weight right they
haven't denied that what they're pushing
back against is there is they're they're
claiming that there's a low certainty of
evidence that going from sugars to low
calorie drinks over the long term
confers a benefit right whereas the
studies we have going up to one year
they do show a benefit but they're
looking at the observational data that's
been done over 10 years worth of time
not just one year right how could they I
guess I just don't understand the point
why did they do this why does the title
say they warrants against using
yeah because because they're looking at
the links between people that drink low
calorie drinks and increase risks of
diabetes heart disease and like certain
types of cancers right and the factors
are the ones drinking the drinks yes as
I've already pointed out and we're all
gonna die pretty young so yes obesity is
is
honestly like the second biggest risk
factor for for overall cancer you can
increase your risk of certain cancers by
about 400 between one to four hundred
percent really whereas uh yeah smoking
is is number one by a clear margin it
can increase your risk of certain lung
cancers by sixteen hundred percent right
whoa but yeah yeah smoking's on a whole
nother level obesity still up to four
times increase for certain types of
cancers now when you when you're
following a group of people that drink
sweeteners for 10 years who are most
likely going to be overweight they are
going to have a greater incidence of
heart disease diabetes and cancer yeah
right so that's why I'm pushing back
against their slightly misleading
statement even though it is technically
correct based on the evidence we have
they they haven't conveyed the message
to the public well enough I don't think
and the newspapers don't understand what
they're saying so they're making kind of
uh inappropriate headlines as well got
it it's definitely sensationalized
headline yes so you call it reverse
causality yes yes they acknowledge that
in this study but do they have any any
evidence at all because it seems to me
that even putting this study out in the
face of evidence that you showed us if
that's like established and well
understood yeah it seems to me
pointless to the point of even being
harmful to put this out why did they put
this out I don't understand this
interesting point I think it's it's
probably
um to combat you know when when like a
new field of health research comes out
right let's say like a new a new natural
like a new natural herb has been shown
to have anti-cancerous properties right
you have hundreds of Wellness creators
who might not understand the details of
that paper they will end up making
videos going like oh everyone who wants
to prevent cancer get on this natural
herb and have it every day right so
because the wellness industry takes it
so far the other way
where it becomes over over
sensationalized and Beyond what is
actually the data is showing yeah I
think the who are trying to put it back
into context by saying look every single
health coach is now saying that if you
want to lose weight go to low calorie
drinks right so they're trying to add a
bit of realism a bit of context of the
to the conversation which is if you
don't drink sugary drinks and you don't
have a sweet tooth then you probably
what you probably won't have that much
benefit go just automatically starting
to drink low calorie drinks that seems
self-apparent yeah I mean yeah yeah you
would say that but a lot of people do
recommend low calorie drinks even if
they don't drink anything sweet anyway
interesting right
um so I think they're trying to
[Laughter]
you know if you're watching this is the
water talk drink oh my God it's horrible
I don't know what's in there
it's like a sharper
Starburst flavored water
yeah uh Starburst and like three pumps
of uh caramel I believe it was yeah and
uh and maybe some Peach and something
else too you're the one saying the
artificial sweetener is great I want to
get a steak actually yeah let me show
you how much but how much do you need
right yeah yeah let me show you this let
me show you this uh which one should I
show them do you think Martin the the
pound cake or the pink Drink the pound
cake the the one with the butter okay so
so there's this water top internet they
have quote water recipes okay and uh
well to be totally fair they all seem to
be trying to sell something in the
description so classic yeah but there
it's not there's no sugar in it these
are artificial sweeteners and so my
thing is like is this good that they're
drinking more water or is this bad
because it's just vile and they're
taking it too far you tell us
hi internet another day another flavored
water sleigh let's go so I just got home
from work I've been rocking my big
natural hair and now it's time for us to
make my final water of the day so
today's water is going to be inspired by
one of my all-time favorite desserts a
lemon pound cake to get started grab
your favorite 40 ounce cup I'm not using
my Stanley today because I got a clear
cup for you so that you can see the
drink fill it up with about 35 ounces of
water and 5 ounces of ice but to be
honest today I just kind of winged it so
do whatever you want okay so for the
powders we're going to start by using
one lemonade packet I got mine from HEB
but any lemonade packet will do and now
for the syrups to get the cake flavor
you're going to be using vanilla almond
so you're gonna do one two three pumps
of vanilla almond into the cup and then
for The Buttery flavor you're going to
use caramel so you're gonna do one and a
half pumps of caramel into the cup all
right you know the drill we're gonna mix
mix until all of that powder is
dissolved okay so I went ahead and I put
the lid on and now it's time for the
taste test
mmm whoa whoa
wow it's light it's refreshing it's
perfect
a decadent lemon pound cake very light
yeah what do you think of that doctor
this is this is exactly what I mean like
the wellness industry just takes things
way too far like in everything right so
even if something does have inherent
benefit they will push it so far to the
point where it starts having harm right
it's like what what's the point but I
love Doctrine and I think it's very
interesting what you're doing I think
it's fascinating I just was listening
into it and I was really really
fascinating but I think it's a little
bit misleading as well what you just
said about or not you said but about the
studies been done about water versus
slow sweetened drinks and I'm not
listening to your videos I'm sorry about
this I will start to do this because
it's really fascinating me but I think
and we had a strong point and obviously
you're agreeing with that because
obviously for me it's all about water
water water water I don't do anything to
it I'm not adding [__] to it nothing to
me it's just pure water actually pure's
a terrible word for water because in
water is minerals dissolved what gives
extra water taste so for two things what
I'm a little bit disagreeing with the
studies what you just showed us first of
all in the one side it says versus water
and then you showcase us for uh blood
pressure
so what kind of water are we talking
about are we talking about processed
water purified water Spring Water
mineral water Healing Waters extremely
high in magnesium or calcium or sodium
would come from other nature these
minerals can have an impact as well on
blood pressure there's been studies been
done in Germany we have all the bath and
Spartans for sure you know this is fall
all over Europe where people are going
and treating themselves on these Healing
Waters to treat themselves and not by
holistic ideas by normal ideas we have
over 60 water brands in Germany who
falling under the medication law in
Germany were actually considered
medication not for hydration their
medication so for saying oh it's just
water on the one side and on the other
side are low carbonated beverages that's
a little bit too awake for me because
water I know can be
super low on minerality and can be so
high that clearly has an impact the
second study where I'm a little bit like
misleading I think is like the idea of
when you're drinking
um low carbonate or like Low sweetener
drinks it's about this sweet tooth so
that means I will not eat going to The
Cheesecake Factory afterwards and eating
then a cheesecake therefore I will lose
weight okay that is kind of like okay
but like when I'm in a first place don't
have a sweet tooth and I think you
mentioned already then there is no
benefits from Spring Water going to
sweetener Waters and I think we all can
agree on that because I almost had a
heart attack when I saw this study there
yeah yeah so several several interesting
points just so I don't forget the last
thing you just said so if you look at
the demographics that are being tested
right they're often people with obesity
and often people who are overweight and
often people that have pre-diabetes or
all type 2 diabetes right now think
about their dietary habits that they
would have needed to become like that in
the first place
you can you can almost guarantee that
the majority of them would have a sweet
tooth oh 100 yeah so that's why in those
populations which unfortunately is the
majority of the US now 70 of us adults
are classified as overweight or obese 70
really yeah more than more than 70 I
think it's four forty percent are
actually clinically obese and another 33
on top of that are classified as
overweight but a bunch of idiots so so
so basically when you look at that
demographic there does seem to be in
some cases a benefit if someone is
trying to lose weight when they go to
low calorie drinks that tends to Stave
off some of the cravings and some of the
you know the late night snacking they
might indulge in and some of the you
know when you go out to a restaurant
they might not feel the need to have a
dessert all of a sudden because they've
had to because they've had two glasses
of of Diet Coke right if we're talking
about myself and you who are from what I
can see we're probably within the
healthy weight range right we we don't
have we don't have obviously really
powerful sweet twos to the point where
it ruins our dietary habits too much
right so whether me drinking this
actually helps me more than if I was
just drinking water I can't say for sure
because our dietary Habits by definition
aren't too extreme either one way or I
agree with you I'd really agree with you
and now the second point that you said
about the types of water very true there
are lots of different types of water
that have lots of different composition
of mineral content however what I would
push back on that is I don't know of any
good data when looking at the types of
water I have here or the types of water
Ethan has next to him over there in the
natural water supply that show that
switching between those different types
of water confers a significant effect
where it would actually change your
blood pressure on a clinically
meaningful level so if you took two
brands of water and you did a controlled
study over a period of two months I
don't think you would find any
statistical significance between the two
groups so even though there are
differences between the waters I think
because the differences are relatively
marginal compared to other dietary
habits like having you know salted meats
or salted snacks or crisps or whatever
I felt it was necessary to group water
together and compared water to low
calorie drinks because I don't think
that in the inter-individual changes
would matter too much that was my
thinking but I do agree that there are
differences in water of course
and I think that is like something what
I think the studies always a little bit
confusing you have to look at the whole
lifestyle of an individual what you just
said and I totally agree with you there
but to say oh we just looked at it and
we didn't look what else they're doing
in their lifestyle that doesn't work for
me that does not work for me because 50
of my health is pretty much what I'm
eating and drinking yes yes yes yeah so
my friend the definition of a randomized
controlled human trial is actually you
are controlling for all these other
factors so when they reach so when they
study the participants the reason why
it's a stronger form of evidence
compared to just observing people in the
community it's a stronger form of
evidence because you're checking their
dietary habits you're using validated
food frequency questionnaires to make
sure that they're consuming relatively
the same types of foods you're looking
at their exercise habits you're looking
at their smoking you're looking at their
sleep equality you're looking at and you
and on top of that you run statistic you
run statistical analyzes where you
adjust for any differences
in you know exercise habits or you know
waist circumference or you know uh
insulin resistance markers right so
there are lots of very clever
mathematical models that you can employ
Within These research studies that
account for the vast majority of the
things that you're describing because as
we both know they are important
lifestyle factors can affect your you
know lots of Lifestyle factors can
affect your health outcome right
absolutely that's the difference between
an observational study at a really
simple level I don't want to get too in
depth because it's going to lose the
audience but at a simple level a
randomized control trial is more
controlled because it's in the name than
a observational cohort study and the
issue is you can't really run randomized
control trials for 10 years because you
know a single a single study would cost
tens of millions of pounds and wants to
be controlled for 10 years yeah yeah
exactly exactly yeah yeah problematic so
but exactly but there was one for
example to to to to end this because why
I was so Furious about this idea of like
studying and then they're putting
something out there was a meal company
who's who did a study about milk is
better absorbed and is hydrating more
your body than water okay and that they
went with that on big billboards in
America and said milk is better
hydrating and I think that is really
misleading to the consumer because again
they looked at obviously the middle
composition of milk as well realize yes
they are these electrolytes who will
absorb faster into your body then
obviously distilled water who does not
have electrolytes therefore that water
will not be absorbed by the body so fast
so and that is my problem because it's
not fair to say oh it's water
yeah again there's too much variety for
me by water because I know it so well
and it's totally fine that you
disagreeing slightly with me that you
think yeah it's kind of like I actually
agree with you because the most
Americans are drinking kind of like the
same water the TDS between 20 and let's
say 300 that's most of the water brands
you can find here in America so they're
very similar but when you're Outreach a
little bit to a different country
suddenly you will realize and I have one
water here this has a tedious of 30 30
000 TDS the ocean is 38 000. this water
has 30 000 TDS it has nothing to do with
water anymore that is a flavored
extremely flavored beverage by Mother
Nature I should not consider this as
hydration product that's medication and
it's labeled as many yeah yeah so so so
so some of those Waters would be medical
grade to the point where you could even
Infuse it in in like an IV bag right
correct yeah so for example for example
we use you know in hospital every day we
use sodium chloride with a bit of
potassium correct with a bit of yeah
purely because they are slight they're
better hydrating than just water yeah
right so yeah you're right you're right
but uh and unfortunately a lot of these
um studies don't actually specify the
composition of the water because I think
you'll see that it would be interesting
because it would be it would be but I
think if you look at the countries in
which they're conducted I don't think
that the average like you take a group
of a thousand people the differences in
uh mineral composition from the water
that those thousand people are drinking
I think will be quite small I think
it'll be pretty small can I ask though
like in the case of the study you say
with the milk using distilled water
that's not like a good water to drink on
a daily basis right distilled water or
is it the same because as I understand
it without at least a baseline of
minerals and stuff it's
your body will signalize right away by
distilled water what is obviously
created for small appliances in your
iron uh your taste pedal will right away
say it's super dry on your mouth feeling
because it it lacks the minerality I
would as a water somebody never ever
drink distilled water that's for me just
unheard of why you should drink that
that's for me companies who want to sell
you the stuff what they're already
producing for your iron and they want to
gain a new Revenue Center and they came
up with this whole idea of pure pure
pure pure water needs to be pure and
should no minerals dissolved and and I
think your body wants minerals most of
them we obviously getting from our food
but when you have a very bad diet you
might be lacking certain minerals and
some Waters have tons of metals
dissolved so so if your drinking
distilled water you probably would still
get all the minerals you need from food
right when you have a balanced diet yes
or what about an unbalanced diet I mean
how because a lot of food we eat is
fortified isn't it yeah yeah yeah in the
Western World I don't think not many
people are struggling with especially
sodium uh even things like potassium
there there's a bit of uh debate around
magnesium but to be honest I've seen
thousands of patients blood tests I I
rarely see a magnesium deficiency
um if I do it's it's usually you know in
an elderly population that that
struggles with you know normal
day-to-day habits
um I yeah I think the Western diet does
pretty well to give us give us an
abundance of everything right we're very
rarely deficient in anything but we have
an abundance of everything right whereas
in many Eastern parts of the world they
they genuinely have deficiencies in
their diets that need to be you know
medically intervened and you know
they've they've had great success with
iron fortification in cereals and things
like that you know things added to
grains but yeah in the West the world we
don't have an issue with deficiencies we
have an issue with over consumption and
too much okay so
interesting conversation between the two
of you thank you well thank you so much
doctor I learned a lot but no no thank
you I appreciate you you're the best and
so is Martin's the best too I feel like
I can put the rest my worry about
um artificial sweetener really I think
so so where did you decide then tell me
when I saw this study
[Laughter]
the brand is for me like a little
borderline but
um but but he drinks that that beverage
what he has is 99 water oh yeah I would
probably say it's even more than 99 yeah
it's yellow beverage right yeah but I
brought a flavor oh yeah for you guys I
considered a flavored water guys
[Applause]
I still have to say though Dr IDs yes
yeah Martin is very polite and he's very
um
he's not combative but our next dragon
for you too
so to speak is uh love who's come armed
and ready for combat all right arm to
the head down to the toes not a water
sommelier but he is top ranked in Call
of Duty
his pill to death ratio is insane I
can't lie I've had I've had many wins in
the original war zone
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right so so love
um do you want to unsheath your sword
and so last time we we kind of argued I
went the wrong route because I tried to
disprove you uh by by saying the facts
were wrong right and that won't work
because I'm not a scientist and I can't
prove facts wrong so I want to start off
this uh by saying like I'm a skeptic I'm
skeptical to to things I'm not a like a
scientist denier I I see I see uh signs
and I I believe it I even like drink
squash it's literally the same same as
you
uh so I'm very very interested in in
something that is called uh people call
it industrial strength denial right this
is some heavy [__] it's a book by
Barbara fries
environmentalist uh lawyer or attorney
and she speaks about kind of these
things that has in history kind of
talked about
um kind of been pushed to be safe some
examples are the coal industry uh global
warming
cigarettes uh toe back on like even seat
belts a bunch of car companies like kind
of try to disprove the the like that
seat belts actually helped uh ozone all
this stuff right yeah uh so I figured I
I would take that kind of approach to
sugar or uh fake sugar okay uh or
artificial sweeteners so I went in and
looked at our previous interview and
looked at every single study you
mentioned and I actually researched who
funded the study
oh follow the money um
extremely extremely in my opinion very
very interesting kind of evidence right
so one of the studies we met okay
this is what's happening right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
and pretty funny did you mentioned both
of these uh study or the both studies
you mentioned today uh are studies that
I knew of yeah and both of these studies
that you mentioned today and a couple
more that you mentioned last episode all
are funded by beverage companies
okay well let me finish okay okay go
ahead love go ahead on these websites uh
if you go down to funding agencies for
example on the John Peter the effects of
water and on nutrients Sweden sweetener
sweeteners beverage and weight loss that
whole thing okay it says the study was
fully funded by the American Beverage
Association okay
that's a good point so what does that
mean it was funded by the no yeah
beverage Association because yeah go
ahead okay so so now this is getting
into slightly higher level stuff I'll
try my best to make it simple so
the reason why the argument that simply
because a research study is funded is
invalid is a little bit naive of how the
research process works so so let me let
me explain so for example
the Jammer
um
the Jammer Journal so that's the Journal
of the American Medical Association for
example yeah
they have a very rigorous uh
research protocol by which any paper
that wants to get published in their
Journal
they need to have an independent data
Handler an independent statistician that
have no links to the research to the
funding body they the researchers often
sign to the people that have funded the
research that whatever the results of
This research shows we will publish it
regardless of what you say absolutely
the reason they do that is because
research has to get funded from
somewhere right governments governments
simply don't have millions and millions
of pounds to spend every single week or
every single month research needs to get
funded number one and research is
expensive especially randomized control
trials where you have to where you have
to closely monitor people over a long
period of time right sure so when you
have rigorous
protocols in place that separate the
funding body to the data collection to
the data synthesis to the statistical
analysis to The Interpreter nation of
the findings to the writing of the
script and also to actually publishing
it in their Journal
people that state oh the funding body
means that the evidence is incorrect
however if you want to have that view
then all of the research that is funded
that is for your argument you need to
dis you need to also throw that out as
well
so hold on this I have an important
Point yeah what about it being funded by
the beverage Association
suggest a bias because they're selling
sugary drinks and artificial insurance
they don't care where the research lies
they're going to sell both of them
yeah yeah but but so you so the point is
is that if you want to get published in
these journals very prestigious journals
the funding body has to be independent
of the data collection and data
synthesis
let me respond real quick yeah so so you
have a problem please hold on love so
you have a problem first of all Dr is is
saying the data has to be collected
impartially and then I'm also saying
even before you get to that I don't see
a possible conversation because they
they're going to make money on both
sides go ahead there is a clear trend
for people to become healthier and
people people are shying away from real
sugar and obviously they are trying to
capture both markets that is the that is
the idea yes if they were not capturing
both markets people would go otherwear
away from Coke away from Pepsi these big
companies so I think even your point is
fair but I think it's pretty obvious
that they are trying to capture people
running away from Coke and running away
from normal soda sure and then to answer
your question or your your stuff you
said it's uh
my point is not necessarily that the the
the facts in the research are wrong but
my point is that if if if uh let's say
Coke and Pepsi are can give money to
specific uh researchers that are going
to research specific uh um
kind of topics right that they could
technically fund things that are looking
looking more promising for them and it
will cause a long-term bias where one
side of the argument will have more
money and they can kind of choose and
pick which which
which kind of things to fund right and I
to back this point up is
I gathered all these uh what you call
them
a research kind of things that you
mentioned and all all five from last
episode were funded in some way of uh
International sweet sweeteners
Association Nestle calorie control
Council which Coke and Pepsi are in
uh but all those were were funded by
these kind of big soda right and big
soda yeah big soda right and I actually
looked through your tick tocks and
looked at kind of your old
um videos where you talk about fake
sugar yeah and two two tick tocks I saw
you mention two studies that were kinda
critical against artificial sweeteners
okay so I I figured I'll fact check
myself let's check if this critical uh
critical studies are also funded by big
big soda right sure and they just so
happened and I haven't done a deeper
control of this I've just these two
studies that I found you being more
critical against it both of these
studies happen to not be funded by big
soda so these two two studies being
critical against soda are not funded by
big solar and all these other ones that
you cited that are pro are founded by
soda so in my head obviously not super
definitive is creating a pretty obvious
bias that's kind of my main point here
okay no no it's yeah it's a good point
so well I would say for mine yeah we're
trying to be respect player of the porn
no no so so there's several things my
decision to address a a critical study
of sweetness is largely due due to media
coverage rather than anything else right
so because those two papers I think one
on Aretha told recently and one on uh
another one maybe on the neutronet Sante
cohort in France that looked at cancer
risk or heart disease risk and
sweeteners right
using the two examples at which I've
been critical of the paper's findings
the meta-analyzes that I cited that
you're stating are funded remember
that's not one study each of those
papers have included dozens of
individual studies and the results of
those individual studies you can look if
you know how to look at the data so when
I showed you that kind of uh those
graphs right yeah that's taking the so
they actually list out all of the papers
they use
a meta-analysis also runs a bias check
so they any any well-conducted
meta-analysis will actually tell you
about the risk of bias right whether
it's high medium or low so we have to
remember that each of those references
are cited they include dozens of
individual studies where if you looked
deeper you would find that many of them
in favor of low calorie drinks are not
funded by Big Oak or Diet Coke that's
actually my question I I wanted to ask
you because when you brought up oh these
big Studies have a bunch of smaller ones
how yes so those smaller studies that
are in this big study so they they are
it it's made sure that they are not
biasedly picked
no no so so it's not it's not about
biasedly picked so when so when you run
a meta-analysis you're asking a very
specific question so you have an
inclusion criteria and an exclusion
criteria right so when so basically what
that means is for example you want
controlled human studies that have
lasted over two weeks that are testing
overweight people where they went from
sugars to low calorie drinks so you've
already got three inclusion criteria
there and then you want to exclude
people that have cancer liver disease
you know type 2 diabetes for example
right so when you run that those that
criteria through a database you then
combine all of the the relevant research
papers given that specific criteria then
you run a meta-analysis on those dozens
of papers now all of those dozens of
papers are listed out individually how
many people they tested what the results
showed they have they have links to all
of the individual papers that they
assessed and you can look at each
individual one of them if you know how
to navigate research right and you'll
see that a lot of them are independently
conducted well they were independently
funded we can do this we should do this
I mean because because we can just put
our own bet well no we should just look
and can see like of whatever like
whatever you think is the meta-analysis
we looked at so that we can actually
look at the studies and then see how
many are funded by because then calls it
but then but then you would need to look
at the journal is published in what the
journal protocol is for publishing a
paper because they all have different
criteria right some lower powered
journals that aren't very prestigious
and don't have much clout around them
they won't do any kind of peer review
process right if you just pay a certain
amount of let's say 800 pound or a
thousand pound you can apply for your
paper to get published they'll briefly
look over it and if it if it looks like
it makes sense you can then publish it
right but anyone in Academia knows that
if you want to get into the bigger
journals they're more prestigious
journals like that paper I just cited is
that's from the Jammer Journal that I
think that's literally that has the
highest impact factor of all Health
journals I think I think sure
um what that means is they are so s
they're they're so they have such a
robust and stringent protocol where the
funding body plays literally no role in
the research that is the only way you
can publish your paper in that journal
so you know I agree with you yeah so so
all I'm all I'm saying is if you want to
hold the view that I will discredit
results based on funding then you need
to discredit all of the funded results
in favor of your opinion as well because
there are many right there are many
funded papers on Diet Coke
so funded by The Diet Coke industry or
whatever yeah the low calorie industry
yeah yeah that have shown negative
impacts or associated with weight gain
or associated with an increased risk of
cancer or cardiovascular disease right
there are trust me as someone that does
research for a living right and is going
to publish papers himself
there are papers that are funded that
show to and they show for and against
right it's just the ones that are
covered in the media tend to be of of a
certain type because that's what
generates the most clicks and Views well
we should we can do we can look at it we
can do that but Mike I think this is
important too to consider because as
Love's original point was that well we
used to have studies saying cigarettes
were healthy I don't I don't I that
that's simply not true okay well maybe
we didn't have we we never had to the
same extent for example Aspartame is the
most heavily studied food additive in
existence in existence right you've got
to remember underlying the signs I'm
just this is for me to be skeptic yeah
love you you are well within your right
to be skeptical and you've raised some
actually very intellectual points right
okay points that I get I get brought
with on a daily basis right all I'm
trying to help you people with is the
final Nuance surrounding how the
research process actually works because
people think conducting research is easy
no it's not easy and there are lots of
steps that you may not know about that
I'm trying to explain to you so there
are lots of steps that even even if a
researcher is being paid to do the
research there are many protocols in
place that can protect that researcher
from having to publish a bias result
right so there are lots of these things
and that's obviously researchers have to
make a living so they have to get
funding from somewhere right and any you
know uh what's the word researcher that
has Integrity that has you know has
treaded that path multiple times they
know how the process works and they can
easily formulate documents with their
research team and be like look thank you
for the offer to fund This research
study I'm going to tell you now when you
sign this whatever the results show we
will publish it whether that's for or
against you right and lots of journals
require this and lots of researchers
require this so I think just the logic
that people go are you know funded by
Diet Coke or funded by big seed oil or
funded by you know tobacco industry that
you can't just negate findings based on
funding body that's all I'm trying but
was there ever one of these like okay
maybe cigarettes is a bad one but like
seat belts or something there's got to
be a vertical where there was some
funding that suggested
back then during those studies were
these these these uh
uh
protocols where the process calls the
same back then or were they looser no no
so very good point and I will say that
because every
everyone that has access to a phone or a
computer
as access to read these studies
themselves right the one many are many
are free to to read the whole thing
through and at the very least you'll be
able to read the abstract right this was
not widespread 20 30 years ago right
people and organizations and academics
and scientists and doctors they almost
they almost had like secret knowledge
that the layperson did not have access
to right so I do agree that back then
before the age of you know publicly
available research databases you know
PubMed uh anyone that has access to a
computer and knows how to type words
will be able to find research studies on
pretty much anything now yeah so this
makes it this makes it far easier for
people to call out obviously biased
research and to call out
um people that are making false claims
based on the research that they think
they're reading so you're saying back
then these these uh research articles
were just bogus just no no no I'm not
saying that I'm saying it if if someone
wants you and if they had if they had an
agenda you would be able to spin a
narrative easier back then okay because
because infamous Nation wasn't as
publicly available
now anything any person loves right love
went and looked at those studies right
30 years ago he wouldn't have been able
to do that all right okay so that's why
you kind of had to almost trust like the
organizations or like trust these
researchers right now you don't have to
trust me I literally showed you the
graph of the 17 end of individual
randomized control studies showing a
benefit for low calorie drinks compared
to sugars now I want to dispel the
I want to dispel
the skepticism what we should do love
let's look not right now obviously but
let's get down and dirty with the 17
studies let's tally them up let's see
who because you know I want to break
through the love we can't break through
to him Dr IDs
so so I've already so even I hear what
you say though I do let me let me just
let me just clarify
even if you looked at all of the 17
individual studies in that meta-analysis
by McGlynn yeah
as I've already mentioned it was
published in Jama right and they have
stringent protocols already in place so
regardless of funding body you can't
dismiss the evidence based on that
anyway right but if you wanted to just
for the sake of because you wanted he
has a he has a skeptical mind doctor
that's why it's an issue here though
that's fine I'm not arguing that what
they are what the studies themselves say
I'm arguing that there's there's a more
a bigger bias right sure more studies
are being done for x and not for example
I found one study where uh it said
um State trigger is bad right yeah and
then Coke came or the the the shell
company that they all use came and
funded a bunch of scientists to debunk
it for example
like two million dollars or something
like that okay would that have been done
the other way around would there come
someone else and put two two million
into researchers from someone else to
well other way we have to think well you
have to think about you know what is the
incentive for publicly funded
organizations to fund that two million
pounds of research
you're saying would that have been done
the other way around I'm asking you if
you were a government and you had x
amount of money would you bother using
tens of millions of pounds just to you
know make more research with the
sometimes but sometimes not the both
yeah exactly because after the
researchers that you said and I'm
um for example that Stevia causes
changing your microbiome and ESR sport
10 changes your mood things that you
have yes negatively it causes depression
yeah both of these things you have never
mentioned I think yes I have no I have
but not on our show right oh no no oh
well I know I did I think uh I think one
of the first times I mentioned if you're
if you're predisposed to having episodes
of low mood there are some small
randomized control trials showing that
people who consume a lot of aspartame
that might exacerbate their periods of
low mood and I think that was a 2014
study that's interesting off the top of
my head
um but then again you have to look at
once again
you have to also remember that findings
can also happen bindings can also happen
due to Chance
is Diet cook making me sad
do we like sucralose does that one make
me sad
my friend my friend I all of them can be
grouped together and I would I'm
perfectly happy saying for the vast
majority of people all of the
non-nutritive sweeteners are perfectly
safe right you have to remember dosage
frequency and the overall context of
what else is going on in your life are
also important
just because I say something is safe
that doesn't mean you find a kilogram of
the powder and you start inhaling it
is a quick follow-up follow-up yes uh
you said it was a small trial right so
yes there have been a couple of small
trials we want we would want to research
that more yes do you think Coke should
have funded doing more research into
that oh absolutely they do that all the
time do you see why would they do that
because because we need so number one we
need more data number one and number two
number two because when the evidence is
kind of like we're not really sure right
one of the big multi-conglomerates or
one of the major billion dollar
companies they'll be like you know what
we don't really know people are becoming
confused let's just firm this one way or
the other right because if it turns out
that aspartame you know majorly
increases your risk of major depressive
disorder right you know what they'll do
they'll change their formulation after
all the headlines get catch catch like
wind of it so actually did with uh
cyclamate right yeah yeah so so actually
it's in their interest to fund it
because then they're not gonna get the
backlash later on right for as you use
as an example of cigarettes weren't all
those companies sued for basically lying
about the health benefits of cigarettes
like a lot of them got have a huge
liability of misleading people about the
the
um
so it's possible that coke wants to
knows to to better assess their their um
uh liability
Coke has done that multiple times in
history like in the 70s they use
cyclamate instead of uh I don't know if
it was instead of a sport team but it
there were some studies that came up
it's cancerous and
um they stopped using it at least in
America they still use it in some parts
of the world yeah and and also remember
that that these that these funded uh
papers also influence you know
um Health policy whether you know the um
the efsa so the uh European Food Safety
Authority or the the FDA whether they
balance us and ingredients whether they
ban certain you know compounds where you
have to force industry to change with
the regulations that's actually a good
thing for these big companies they they
they would rather know earlier than
after you know 15 years of questionable
research and then you know them them
losing market share because you've got
Tom Dick and Harry Wellness Guru being
like stay away from Diet Coke because
they still use this this like
questionable artificial sweets now it's
not in their interest to to you know to
include questionable ingredients in
their products sure because
we're at the same same page at this
point yeah yeah all right so I brought
up some stuff I thought was interesting
and it was love I gotta say I was it was
it was it was it was interesting
damn what I would actually argument with
all this topic is we all know that big
companies need to make money and I have
a feeling obviously I don't know exactly
what the measurements are but I have a
feeling that a Diet Coke is cheaper to
produce than a regular Coke with real
sugar interesting yeah probably that is
yes for me for sure
that's a good point as well
whole diet idea because they're saying
Hey listen we need to make money let's
be honest here it's all about money in
there for sure so Fantastic Four for
them it's I think it's easier to push
that love is love into this idea of
let's put study spin down let's have the
data there that Diet Coke is may be
safer than non-artificial sweetener and
they will actually smile at that they
will love that idea of
okay now let's drink all Coke Zero and
Diet Coke obviously I don't know I don't
have the studies there I don't know but
yeah from a just stand point there it's
for sure Harder To Source real sugar and
to put it into a factory than to create
a cocktail of some artificial flavors
so they're very very very good point I'm
not sure how the health economics uh
what all the opportunity cost between
high fructose corn syrup in the US I
know that's very cheap we use something
similar we have glucose fructose syrup
and we have normal just like sucrose as
well
um I think that high fructose corn syrup
is exceptionally cheap in the U.S I
might be wrong but I know you're right
it is I'm not sure the health economics
is practically free here yes yes but
what I would say is that you have to
remember that you know it's not it's not
just it's not just about the money even
though that is the major component the
other point is is about the legality and
the liability side where if it turns out
in 10 years time that Diet Coke have
been harming people with these compounds
massive lawsuits
oh yeah in in the ways of 50 hundreds of
millions of pounds they could easily
lose right so they don't want to be
intentionally harming people that is not
in any anything organizations right so I
think this whole like narrative that I
get in in my comments a lot whereas
through them why is every time I call
Comcast every time there's a [__] uh
you know increase in my bill they just
give me the runaround I'm sorry I'm just
kidding I think um I think that we've
all
we've gone places haven't we I've
learned a lot definitely I think so yeah
can I can I get can I get your your view
I
I feel like
um Dr IDs you are very informative and I
feel like I have been persuaded oh
that's big for me that is big that's the
most important person right I think that
the studies we looked at were really
powerful and I I feel like I love is
Raising really good points but I see it
from your perspective because in real
life unfortunately things are very
expensive and they do need to be funded
but also like you are saying I'm sure
there's so many levels to to make a
study legit like you said you know
there's there's criterias they need to
meet and checkpoints whatever it is
obviously I've never done one but I'm
sure there there's so many so
I think that I'm I'm a person of like
trust the
trust the organization or trust you know
the scientists who studied it their
whole life that yeah they're doing
what's best so I will say based on our
research here just to address your point
that it is in general
less expensive to produce Diet Coke for
whatever that's worth okay yeah yeah
that's that's probably simply because
the volumes you need are like to the
fold of 200 times less right right so
like per drink because it's obviously
200 times sweeter you need then
obviously 200 times less so yeah
probably
all right that makes sense so um
so in short licks and we're water we're
Water Club we can all agree on one thing
water talk is demonic
what I brought today yeah I really want
to try it's a real story so I'm not
making that up this real flavored water
comes from our 700 feet deep well it's
sourced by the German Alps from Munich
and it takes around 12 000 years
from rain water to come to this well
age to Perfection and this very
beautiful flavored water is called beer
in Germany what oh
how old it is
it's 95 water
[Music]
I drink as a hydration when I'm at the
airport because the most of the time the
selection airport sucks when it comes to
water wow
that's a party and this we drink cold
right Mark yeah I have a cold I have ice
packs filled up here oh my God
what a gracious uh guest wow thank you
this is a this is your favorite or is
this one yeah that's a great that's a
great deal that's just a very very good
beer
so um thank you guys both I'm gonna have
to we should get some cups and pass this
around absolutely yeah let's all try it
nice and that's very cold oh yeah we
drank beer we drank beer
uh thank you everybody for a lively
debate
a great respectful Illuminating debate
super interesting love came with some
very interesting points I gotta say
thank you although I've not heard from
I've not heard from a b
i I don't know why everyone just counted
me out of this but I'm I'm glad I'm not
taking no heat no no I I we want to hear
you not until now yeah can I can I just
quickly just I need to ask just a
sensitive question because it's rude of
me not to check on your progress since
the last time we spoke about a sensitive
issue oh
Soldier doing okay hahaha thanks Doc yes
I appreciate it okay it's okay we're
good we're good baby snapped his dick
for those who don't know the details
okay Martin Abe was having sex with his
wife in the shower and the dick good for
him crush
and so he had he had major bruising and
Dr IDs was Consulting us on the issue
right Abby yeah yeah can I get a can I
get a concluding remark from a B on his
views on the uh the diet drinks yeah
please no I'm with you dog I just I
think I'm with love in that he was just
trying to prove the point that he's he
it's him being skeptical like there is a
reason for him to be skeptical which is
pretty much what he was you know trying
to get across because last time we got
roasted saying that oh I bet love baby
or anti-vaxx and a bunch of other stuff
but I think love presented a really good
case as to why it's okay to be skeptical
about the stuff it's this is not covet
it's something completely different sure
yeah sure sure and let me just say let
me just say quickly before I have to go
basically
I have no problem saying if he would
rather stay away from low calorie drinks
I'm not saying you should just go and
drink low calorie drinks right I'm
saying that you don't need to be scared
of them and the totality of data shows
they're perfectly safe like these things
have been studied in the ways of
hundreds I'm talking hundreds of
individual research papers right so I'm
going to live my life based on the data
that's how I live my life I'm not scared
of any single ingredient I will happily
consume any food once or twice right I
know because I understand toxicology I
understand that you're not going to get
cancer from eating something once have
you eat the hardship
the spicy Chip have you done the chip
challenge oh no no oh no no you should
do that on our show
I can't handle too much space
I want it so I want to thank you for uh
dealing with me once again
um
I hope most of the viewers realize I
this is pretty much me asking you
questions yeah you're answering and most
of the times I would not I would not
even call it a debate I would call it a
very nice discussion we had a lovely
discussion lovely thank you just to put
a pin in this last time after our
conversation the audience was still
split
as to if artists with artificial
sweeteners were totally wrong or not
totally safe or not last time I believed
they even swung saying they're still
skeptical this time we did the pull
artificial sweetener
I maybe it's a bad pole bad pole yeah
you should be skeptical it says it
should say artificial sweetener
safe or why are you still skeptical well
I guess oh my God or you could say safe
safe or harmful safely I think this is
fine okay so but harmful is so
aggressive yes well according to that
poll 60 said safe which is a massive
progress over Alaska okay cheers by the
way
clearly you guys have an intelligent
audience oh the water
well we'll see into when we reword it
right
because I I don't think it's bad for you
I'm just skeptical oh my goodness
awesome huh
artificial sweetener wait that tastes
really good what is the what is this
called again it's a heifer weissen so
it's a wheat beer oh I love wheat beer
let's go that's awesome wait why does
that taste so good because it's Ramen
because it's German they know what's up
over there I usually don't like the
taste of beer at all all the time
smooth damn Martin this is delicious not
so good holy [__] love it if you guys
are wondering the brand hold on it's one
of the very very famous beer brands in
Germany excellent you can buy the Jones
for 12 000 years yeah really like it's
not rain water it's like the story what
I just said was all true yeah this
toasting the well water from the Alps
under Munich 700 feet deep is it like
expensive compared to other beers no uh
I pull I paid 8.99 for four cans it's a
slightly premium price yeah look you
have to get it into America as well the
Imports a lot it cost you a little bit
more but I think you're getting a great
quality that is the best Martin you
always come in with the facts and
receipts the best flavors of liquids
yeah I
know one more time here artificial
sweetener safe or still skeptical let's
do that
sixty percent it's coming up the same
Paul wasn't a bad pool I think we had a
good poll maybe yeah I thought it was
fine the numbers are the same so they
were it was a good vote Dr Edge we made
some incredible progress I tell you what
I'm voting thank you Doctor safe
this is incredible Ela is out here
it's my pleasure my pleasure guys thank
you so much and so let's say it together
[__] the World Health Organization
no no I don't no I don't work I don't
work for them I've literally had a few
I've had a few emails being like oh we'd
love you to be on our you know
misinformation committee where you you
know help us debunk information okay I
said yes but you know now I have to also
be like guys I don't really accept your
your phrasing I think it's a little bit
misleading so that's what I've tried to
clarify today there it is to Yellow to
Yellow beverage to Yellow beverage all
right thank you very much guys I need to
I need to head off now all right
um but I will just say Ethan if you
don't mind I just have a cheeky little
plug for myself if that's absolutely
please do okay
um so if people are you know any
academics professionals Health
enthusiasts any anyone that's interested
in the more higher level scientific
breakdowns like a little bit kind of
what I got into today just a little bit
um I have just opened my online school
about a month ago where I do
professionally recorded more in-depth
scientific breakdowns of a lot of these
topics so if you're interested then
check out you know my links I have my
website on there as well so that's for
people that that really
it's called the school of Dr IDs
yes doctor if you um if you have a link
uh send it to Olivia and I'll add it to
the description of the episode for you
oh amazing thank you so much thank you
so much uh excellent I I heard I heard
the first iteration Hustler University
[Applause]
it's a little more rooted in evidence
compared to that okay
cheers thank you thank you so much
lovely to meet everyone Martin thank you
very much
I gotta say um love impressed me today
yeah that was very good but you brought
some you brought some heat yep thank you
you had him sweat in there for a minute
I think yeah I I last time I kind of had
this argument I tried to argue the fact
which obviously I can't do I'm not a
scientist I'm not a researcher so try to
find a little bit of a different way
angle yeah were you playing that Chef or
was it Ian
okay I like that that's cool
okay nope so um Martin
um
do you need to leave are you in a hurry
yeah I need to go to Gwen and yeah a
little bit my guest I had a feeling you
yeah coming over all right so but let's
talk I would love if if it's okay for us
all to come visit you there yeah please
please always come over and again like I
cannot thank everybody enough here from
the audience as well yeah like you're
the real Superstars obviously that's
right and it's always fun to see all the
comments on my social and and getting
referred obviously to the H3 podcast so
thank you so much for all the amazing
love and this is family obviously yeah
family it is
what a great episode so you got you can
go ahead I know you're in a hurry thank
you but um
we'll be in touch and I'm really excited
actually to come check out Gwen's me too
that's great that's exciting
and the water drips are
that's basically they're my diarrhea
that's what it sounds like
disgusting it's what it is it's
disgusting those are the kind of drips
that get back up on your ass too oh stop
it
I know exactly what those sound like
we're all enjoying a beautiful beer e of
a diarrhea uh
what do you call it dissolved parts per
what's the what's the acronym TDS to be
honest guys I never checked the TDS of
my diary
the nice show I had to drink urine of
the astronauts of the International
Space Station you did that you can check
it out right now on Netflix wait you
were in build I'm on the bill nice oh no
way whoa they gave me the astronaut
water and this is the water but they're
obviously drinking it out of space yeah
and it's very heavy to bring wardrobe we
see up there so they brought once water
up there and now they're Recycling and
Recycling and recycling all over again
so that means they're collecting their
sweat shower water and urine purifying
it and then drink it again that almost
and it's now strange to say it was super
sweet on my palate ew red water and it
smelled like a dentist office when you
walk into a dentist over there was the
smell of that water was disgusting oh my
goodness
for me not to go out of space
[Music]
stay away from space thank you Martin
thank you nice meeting you thank you for
coming dude
and I appreciate you all so much
Martin's the man I mean who doesn't love
Martin the water God yeah Poseidon I'm
gonna start calling you Poseidon
we have a Poseidon statue of Martin in
that background I don't know if you
noticed oh I did it they pull it up
again look at the
I didn't even notice that's Martin in
the background as as the god of the
ocean God of this you are Poseidon yeah
right there there he is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is the man too what a show see people
were complaining about our Babylon
preach one being like Oh
just one topic now we brought it all
down to science we now he said he was
laughing that we're intellectual well I
guess we are dude thanks here hear that
I am so sorry I've been working on it
put some carpets down something
all right well how long we've been going
Dan uh just about three hours
gee whiz she whiz is there anything else
we wanted to hit on before we go
you could probably save I mean all of
this is barely uh
uh Evergreen I would say and got a bunch
of the Goofs let me see if was there um
there any of the Goofs and gaffs that we
really wanted to cover oh God now I
gotta burp
this beer is fantastic it's one of the
best beers yeah
it tastes like sweet and nice and smooth
what's the percentage on this one
alcohol percentage oh it's 5.5
tastes a lot like beef jerky
oh we do have that clip of fousey uh
speaking of tastes like beef jerky oh we
should do that and also I want to show
that rugs since um right
um a wonderful uh journalist wrote an
article about our beloved Ela
yeah he's here with us today
so Morgan from fashionista is here
[Applause]
[Music]
uh Morgan and her boyfriend who brought
us delicious oh husband husband yeah
husband yeah husband you put a ring on
it huh yeah good for you
uh who brought us the greatest Donuts
I've ever had they are so good
insane but um
okay but um uh uh uh you guys brought us
a rug right so it's a gift from Morgan's
friend I'll let you explain is it here I
haven't seen it it's in the other office
right now okay that makes sense but yes
it is here
it's in the teddy fresh yes yeah check
this out make sense it's a problem it's
probably copyrighted music probably put
something funky on he's got that we've
got that Bye Mom hi Mom shirt on Yo
those carpet guns are so sick so cool
is this what he does is he a carpet
maker
yeah they own a design company called
Baker Hill Design which is their
Instagram so yeah they just toughed rugs
this is the first one they've done with
the design where they pull it out dude
that is
[Music]
yeah
that's awesome that's crazy we
definitely got to put that on the wall
yeah so talented this is Baker Hill
Design shout out yeah shout out they're
like a fancy name for a carpet maker
like like how like a cobbler is like a
Shoemaker
Carpenter carp I'm kidding Carpenter
yeah that's pretty funny look at these
other ones we got Kirby dreamland up in
this [__] that's cool we got this one's
for Olivia
I'm not here
um
these are awesome super talented Baker
Hill Design there it is very cool
um so one last thing Ian was streaming
and then we captured this great moment
um
here it is FouseyTUBE we got some news
drops from fusi thanks to Ian really
some some foot soldiers gotten fousey's
chat and started saying some silly stuff
and we got some new drops you guys are
gonna love this thank you Ian I didn't
know even that he's streaming I didn't
know that about fousey no I didn't know
that raid
h3h3 rated people saying nah nah it was
Mr World worldwide wasted shout out got
the name wrong it's not quite my name
but when you're a king
we are here for vibes okay why is she
reading like that okay
it's like beef jerky
so wait now we have the new drops right
now you pulled those
gay
tastes like B jerky
you're gonna be wasted by the way our
fans are the best they were big men you
know what I mean they're being nice my
understanding is after this happened he
banned the word gay in his chat oh
I felt I kind of really thought he was
getting trolled but it really wasn't
like yeah it's all good fun yeah I love
that my favorite is the I I that's what
I was getting to yeah
tastes like beef jerky I
he's with it I I
I felt gay
oh my God it's like beef jerky
worldwide wasted
all right
so um well it's 4 30 I guess we gotta
wrap it up how it's been about three
hours eh three hours on the dot I know I
went by fast good
Lots going on here
hold on let me see if I got my apology
yet from um uh from Babylon reach
because he said it would be in one day
didn't he say that
that's him laughing he said I'll be out
here one day
wait how come the channels doesn't show
up wow
yeah why doesn't the Channel show up
because their name is in Babylon Ridge
oh it's not
wait what is it Pender and Rich
peaches and cream actually no I just
outside
I denounced that
they took is from uh like a it's like
adult superstore yeah plagiaries
I thought it was funny that day and
I mean I'm fine with that yeah I'm just
kidding but six hours ago and I don't
believe this included an apology for me
so
[Music]
by the way you see what happens when
they create look at their views here
five hundred thousand five hundred
thousand oh Ethan threatens us 1.2
million and now these [__] ain't
going to respond
well we'll see maybe they're fixing
their floor first maybe they let them
cook you know yeah yeah they gave they
said one day they'd be out here maybe he
was being a little hyperbolic okay it's
it's a holiday weekend we'll we'll give
them it is memorial it is it is uh
Memorial and he did serve in the
military too that's right although all
right well he didn't die in Canada he
didn't and also he didn't die yeah
Memorial days for our fallen brave
Soldiers I you didn't die all right all
right all right
you have a taboo I'm sure whatever they
talked about it was taboo
taboo that's my favorite subjects or
taboo
except daughter porn
I don't know why that's a taboo subject
I don't know why I said that so
um we will not be here on Monday uh-huh
we're all taking the holiday to uh
memorialize uh-huh all the great sold
jokes from the Civil War get up everyone
all the way up to Afghanistan
and not the independence workers because
well we can honor them wait it's not in
Nebraska
you mean the Civil War no no you call it
the war of independence are you
Confederate
no the end no bro the one against
Britain oh we gotta honor them too right
no of course why wouldn't we because
well in Nebraska they we're just
honoring the people in Nebraska because
Nebraska didn't exist to be fair
you know shout out to all the brave
warriors thank you for your service
sorry doctors
for honoring the Revolutionary words
thank you for your service uh
sorry about not having health care for
you
sorry about the uh burn pits
[Music]
the good news is we will be putting a
tiny little toothpick flag on Your Grave
so that'll make it all better you seen
those little Flags they do yeah of
course it's like a little toothpick with
the American flag uh-huh
they're like I have lung cancer from
Burn pits like not enough when you die
you get the toothpick
so we're generous country and we really
care about our soldiers out here
mm-hmm
we got a whole day
celebrate them
huge mattress sales too coming out to
honor our brave Fallen Soldiers
IHOP's got deals
[Music]
oh yeah
okay wrongful hey get the [__] out of
here
England [__] yeah now's the perfect time
to head on over to sit and sleep
pick your up as your mattress
killing me laugh
the deals are insane this weekend
Stearns and Foster
uh
I don't know the other brands
call you know what they need uh to have
a sale on is coffins
because it would be more appropriate for
Memorial no I see where you're coming
yeah yeah right
right
yeah but let's get him some health care
okay that's what I'm all here
it's America let's go home and drink
some Coke Zeros
let's pound them
[Applause]
take us out
[Music]
giving just to help her fellow man
standing in defensive right not afraid
to give her all to five
[Music]
America to me